[Laughter]
foreign
hey everybody what's going on yeah what
are we talking about today this I don't
know okay I put a little bit
I put a little bit don't put all this
pressure on me what the hell was that
this light back here I don't know why
but it's like I had this light back here
and it keeps like changing color every
now and then like I can't really figure
out why I'll figure it out it's weird
I'll figure it out later I kind of like
that color that it just did yeah do you
think I could figure out how to like do
that on purpose not RGB [ __ ] up
um I think it was because I backed up
and maybe I ran into the table but it's
like it's not changing well I don't know
but it's like not changing like at a
normal because you know I know it has
like a setting where it goes but it's
just like every now and then it'll just
like change colors just for sure it's
a random color each time no it goes back
and forth from this to like more of a
reddish okay like more like that okay
um it's just going back and forth from
two things I don't get it I never have
fake been able to figure these lights
out to be honest with you yeah there's
controls on the back of it well I know
there are but and I even know how RGB
works because I'm a graphic designer but
I still can't figure out like uh which
button does what or like how to get it
to [ __ ] work I'm gonna say I don't
know something I don't know what you
were gonna think oh I'm saying that
there was um
um in that is a little bit of uh peach
vodka okay well yeah because we only had
a tiny little yeah so I just kind of
diluted a little bit I drank a little
bit of it last night because I was
trying to like finish it out and finish
it up it's good I didn't want to drink
all of it put it on last night while I
was watching Hell's Kitchen lemonade
Peach
and whipped cream vodka
yeah it's good
I mean honestly like last night I just
like I said I was trying to use up the
peach vodka so I just put some peach
vodka in there and a little bit of
lemonade and that was good too yeah it's
not as good as a whipped cream yeah but
it's still pretty good Willow's there
what's up luwillow
said hello Jenny Tom and Pokey yeah
pokey's still back there right she's
right there yeah where'd she go she's
right there playing with a toy she's
back there but yeah she's picking up
picking up a little toy mouse and
hitting it
it's getting away but yeah
she's so funny with those baths she
knows they're not real but it's like I
think she likes to pretend because she
just like sits there and then like she
looks at it like that pretending that
they're real is it gonna move a long
time
[Laughter]
and then she's like [ __ ] it and then she
just jumps on it anyway yeah well I said
I can't see her oh yeah she's
well we can't really move the camera
we'll never really get it she's behind
the chair if I move the chair can you
see her maybe I'd have to move the chair
like way yeah there she is there she is
there she is yeah she's like what are
you doing Mommy yeah are you running
over my babies
yeah I'm not running over your babies I
don't think am I and she's like I don't
like this she's like what are you doing
she's like she's like looking at me
I got too close to her other babies like
when I slid the chair but I didn't hit
it yeah she's checking on him isn't that
funny did you run any of these over did
you
thought you ran him over I didn't yeah I
didn't she's going there checking them I
didn't even get close to the base like
he ran him over I didn't yeah I promise
I would never do such a thing
you're so cute she's making sure they're
all accounted foreign
she's got a whole pile of little toys
yeah dolls and stuff
yeah oh my God and then yeah she just
went over there okay I thought she was
gonna do like the whole brush situation
yeah I told her I told her earlier that
she needed to go to brushies Anonymous
yeah because she loved it we're not
going out tonight now I'm just gonna sit
here and uh entertain y'all
and uh everybody's showing up Oscar's in
there
uh Jeffrey art showing up Jeffy art
Jeffy yeah
you actually have your glasses today so
you can like see yeah he goes in
yeah we're not I figured we probably
wouldn't what the hell that was a
notification of my phone which could be
any number of things could be could be a
text could be a YouTube comment could be
right I don't know what it is I don't
know what it is it just makes that noise
every now and then I'm just like
whatever
um but yeah so what was I gonna say oh
yeah I kind of feel like we probably
should stay in this weekend because
next weekend as I said is Halloween
and so we have to figure out
we have to figure these are the pro the
problems that we have we have to figure
out like which Halloween party we want
to hit
because I don't think I can afford to go
to both of them yeah
you know I can't I was looking at I was
looking at a um at a Bane costume yeah
yeah you know the uh you already have
some of the stuff for that right yeah
for one of them I have I have the Bane
Luchador outfit that yeah that's what I
thought that you have more comic books
yeah I thought you had one yeah but I
was looking at the movie One for uh from
uh Batman
what was it uh oh what's his name Tom
Hardy's yeah you know what the mask and
the
uh vest and the pants and I have a lot
of that
uh I have pants that would work
and Boots definitely that would work
um
it would be close to it'd probably be
close to 200 bucks and I I can't Fork
that out in such a short period of time
I'd have to build that up for next year
I got I got the arms for it
and bald head
see you got to be bald and you got to be
jacked to [ __ ] wear that costume or
it's going to look [ __ ] goofy I'm
trying to think of like what else you
could be I'll just probably just go as
[ __ ] the other Bane I'd probably go
as the damn comic book Bank yeah I mean
you could the Luchador for the [ __ ]
the Denny yeah because you know like I
said suffer that yeah I got a few things
for mine but I think mine's gonna be
cool I think I hope I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to do like a rehearsal like before
I actually go to the party in it because
I don't want to [ __ ] it up and I got
everything except
well there's two things that are still
coming but if those two things don't
come I can still do the costume without
that like I got all the main stuff like
it would be nice to have like these two
little minor things but if they don't
show up then I can still pull it off
without that yeah
um Oscar said the new VHS 99 movie came
out on shutter yesterday yeah I saw that
I think um what I'm gonna do probably on
because I have um a bunch of reviews I
wanted to do like going up to Halloween
but I think what I'm gonna do probably
for the scare Salon site is maybe the
first week in November I'm gonna do a
video about all the VHS movies like I'm
gonna watch because I've seen all of
them up and but I haven't seen the new
one yet so I think so maybe like first
week in November I'm planning on doing
that I'm just gonna like watch all the
VHS movies and do a video about that
so it was so it is coming
but I was yeah because I went on shutter
yesterday because I was watching the um
the 101 scariest movie moments thing
they put a new episode up yesterday so I
watched that last night yeah Oscar said
heck yeah that would be superb yeah I
know I know that um that you and a
couple other people had asked me about
that so and I do really like the VHS
movie so I'll get Tom to watch him he
will dig him yeah he probably would dude
what the VHS movies they're like
anthology horror movies there's a bunch
of them well no I think I've seen the
first one that was a long time ago right
didn't didn't the first one come out a
long long time ago
I can't remember when the first one came
no it wasn't that long ago I don't think
it was it now I can't remember either I
recently I watched VHS 94 like when it
first came out and I really like that
but
the new one's 99 and that one's out but
maybe this is the fourth one right
wasn't there VHS vhs2
VHS 94 or was there another one in
between I can now I can't even remember
I'm trying to like I should probably
check how many movies it is like before
I commit to like doing a video about it
like am I gonna have time to like watch
all these because it happens you know
how like when I first started on my
scare Salon site I was like oh I'm gonna
do the whole like that Boris Karloff um
series Thriller and I was thinking that
it wasn't on TV for that long or it only
had like a few episodes and then I was
like oh I'm gonna do like a video
talking about that series and then I
realized that it had [ __ ] 40 goddamn
episodes and they're like an hour long
each and I was just like oh Jesus Christ
I can't like [ __ ] so I started doing
them in six episode chunks so I just
finished watching like the next six
episodes like today and like wrote a
thing and did a video for that so that's
going up tomorrow but
oh yeah viral that's another one that
I've that's one that I forgot so there's
five movies okay so that's not too bad
I forgot about VHS viral and I don't
think I've seen that one I saw the first
two I saw 94 but I don't think I saw
viral and I haven't watched 99 yet
I made a good [ __ ] um
um
made a good [ __ ] uh what do you call
it uh original dish today I'm gonna call
that [ __ ]
uh
well what would I call that I don't know
what did you call it I forgot to call
that like chicken white trash Supreme
chicken
chicken
chicken cream Supreme I don't know it
was did you put cream of mushroom soup
in it or not with chicken soup in it I
thought I didn't think you had no soup
in it that's what I thought I don't even
think I had a bunch of uh boneless uh
chicken thighs
so I chopped them up cubed them
I put them in a a pan of uh
hot oil
and browned them real quick then I put
in
uh diced onions cooked those
and then I had two green peppers from
the uh Garden put those in there
and then I poured a whole can a big can
of Rotel in there juice and everything
all right on top of that
and then I put a big old chunk of
[ __ ] Velveeta cheese in there
and uh two cups of milk it'll be the
cheese the Vegeta
and then um a teaspoon of uh
um of uh
chicken bouillon
put that in it and then simmered it down
until it got thick and served it over
rice white rice it was good real good
it was very good really easy to make I'm
gonna have some more tonight yeah
it's real easy to make and it was just
like a good Comfort dish
I was gonna make like a Thai curry with
it or some kind of Indian Curry's like
man I'm on American flavors I just put
[ __ ] cheese well to be fair we have
been making a lot of curries yeah too
much curry no I mean not that there's
anything wrong with that because I love
curry both Indians Curry and Thai curry
I just wanted something more Savory and
creamy and Mild you know something white
trashy white trash white trash Supreme
it wasn't it was very good yeah like I
said I'm gonna have some more of that
later yeah it was good
and uh just put it next take a bowl of
white rice put that on half the bowl is
rice and then just to Ladle in some of
that cheesy
cheesy chicken man
with Rotel in it which is tomatoes and
green chilies green peppers and onions
yeah it's good yeah
now Velveeta people think that that's
bad for you that's very good for you
it's all whey protein it's basically the
same thing bodybuilders
drink you know like the uh um protein
drinks it's that same thing if you look
at the if you look at the nutrition it's
good it's low in calorie real high in
protein
doesn't have that much fat in it either
it's just uh whey protein
so it's good for you
Camp guy said I may bail to watch uh the
first terrifier movie with the wife she
said people are fainting and needing
medical attention at the theaters
opening uh the second one I said
publicity stunt yeah I was reading an
article yesterday about that
um I kind of feel that way too because
I'm like look
um
I don't know unless like people that
aren't really into horror or have heart
conditions or something like that are
going to I can't imagine anything that
would be in a movie that would make me
pass out that would be in a movie
you know what I mean it's fake and from
everything I've heard I haven't seen
terrify or two yet but I do want to see
it because I really did like the first
one but um it just mostly looks like
really really super bloody and gory and
it's like that does not bother me at all
like if something's in a movie that's
gonna bother me it's gonna be poop yeah
it's gonna be poop related you know what
I mean like it's gonna be like some [ __ ]
like human centipede or something like
that when I think about like somebody
pooping in somebody's mouth and honestly
that's not gonna make me faint it's just
gonna make me like gag forever you know
what I mean and not want to watch it
that and like you know in like [ __ ] like
audition with like people drinking vomit
and like [ __ ] like that like that kind
of stuff grosses me out like you could
put blood in there all day long and that
doesn't bother me at all Danny's talking
about putting the yellow stuff from like
the Venom the Venom going into Bane's
mask if you guys don't know the
character he's basically being loaded up
with basically steroids
um to [ __ ] help him deal with like
pain and make him stronger I think in
the comic books he stole it some techno
analogy from Batman and made him
stronger the thing is on that mask
the details aren't you can't it doesn't
really stand out I really need I really
need the Venom apparatus
for my uh Mexican Mexican uh Bane
Luchador costume okay because there's a
Mexican Bay too Jay Trejo did the voice
for it in the con in the uh the animated
version
and um
I think that one had I think he had
Venom also but it was in a canister on
his back and it he had damn glowing
lines going down his arm we'd go into
his veins and he could hit a button and
he'd eject himself like that he'd just
get huge and his whole upper body blow
up
looked like he'd weigh [ __ ] 600
pounds
he didn't never explain where the mask
came from you you have to eat to get
that baby he would just get huge you
know and then just start fighting
he had that damn stretchy wrestler
outfit on
Ben says have you watched All Hallows
Eve that's terrifier zero yeah I have
seen that um I watched that probably two
or three Halloweens ago and that is also
very good I've actually seen I don't
remember if we reviewed it I thought we
had
um Jeffy art said I remember Bravo
airing 100 scariest movies in 2004 yeah
I watched that and I actually watched it
again like a year or two ago like on
YouTube
it this is a similar thing but it's like
updated so shutter is doing it and
they're doing
um they put up an episode I think every
Wednesday but I think they're on I think
there's only one more I think there's
only one more because the one that I saw
last night was like all the way up to
like 12 or something like that and then
it's gonna be like down 12 to like one
but yeah it's a good show they got like
Joe Bob Briggs on there it's like it's
it's super fun they got everybody on
there
uh they got Greg nicatero oh and
something that I saw on the thing last
night
in case anybody ever wondered you know
in The Omen when David Warner gets his
head cut off with the pain of glass
um that severed head Greg nicotero has
it he loves that movie so much that he
bought it so he like has it there was
like a picture of him with it and I
thought it was funny because they were
like guys because they were talking
about the omen and uh he's like yeah if
anybody ever asked you what happened to
David Warner's severed head from The
Omen
I got it so I was like I thought that
was like super running
um let's see I'm kind of way behind yeah
American Horror Story I kind of like I
watched some of it and it seemed cool
but yeah I've heard that like the
seasons are very hit or miss and it's
just like I feel like
man there's just so much stuff I gotta
watch and it's just kind of like [ __ ]
I just got so behind on everything you
know what I mean how much was the
Crustle wine okay now here's the thing
apparently I mean at least the ABC
Liquor around here doesn't have it and I
looked on the website for it and every
single variety of it was sold out except
for one kind and that bottle was 75
and I'm like
no wine can be that good I'm sorry it
just can't what's it called
uh I don't I don't remember
that'd be hilarious how [ __ ] funny
Would it be hilarious no it's called
it's called It's called Go
ghee or Goji g-o-g-i which I'm assuming
is Goldie like Geo for Goldie and GI for
do they have a daughter or a son or
something that they're naming it after
that's kind of the first thing and I
could be totally pulling it out my ass
but yeah you're pulling it as you guys
no I'm just saying that's kind of like
the that's the first thing I thought of
I think uh oh I think it would be
awesome if [ __ ] all Kurt Russell
merchandise was now just called Crustle
and then he started calling himself
Russell and it becomes like a brand I'd
have to sue his ass
the honest way you know
[Laughter]
yeah Oscar said Jeffy already used to
love the Bravo's 100 scariest movie
moments I did too like I said I've seen
it multiple times I hear this new one on
shutter is even better I really do like
the one on cheddar it's very very
entertaining and it's cool because they
don't I mean the Bravo One they were
mostly just focused very much on one
scene whereas like the shutter one
because it's so much longer like each
episode they talk about like 10 movies
so they go way more into
the whole movie and not just the scene
you know what I mean so I don't know
it's like I find it really entertaining
I liked it a lot it's actually a couple
of episodes I watch more than once Oscar
said terrifier 2 was disgusting probably
the most vulgar movie ever shown in
theaters oh well now I really want to
see it
I was probably you know Human Centipede
it's worse than that see that's what I
mean that's to me that's like a
different thing like he like stuff like
humans said anything had to do with like
poop or vomit or anything like that
that's gross like sometimes I can watch
it but I'll just be like the whole time
I'm not gonna faint or anything like
that it's just it'll probably just make
me gag
but anything that's bloody like that's
just blood or Gore or guts or something
like that that does not bother me at all
and I don't know why that is but that's
just the way it is
but anything other than thank you very
much he just sent us ten dollars oh
thank you for crestle wine fund crust
away foot we're gonna have to like order
because I was like do I seriously have
to order it they don't have it at the
liquor store
it's specialty and like I said it's all
sold out except for that 175 bottle and
I was just like like I said no wine can
be that good I'm sorry it just can't
what's up Dave hello you two uh Jenny
you look amazing like always thank you
Tom always buff yes he is
probably going to mannequins tonight got
some Voodoo theme happening yeah that's
right tonight was uh
yeah what was I did the poster but I
can't
I can't remember what it was but yeah we
might be at mannequins uh for maybe I
don't know are we doing like for their
Saturday next week we'll we'll work it
out I think I'd probably rather go to
mannequins
because uh I think it'll be a bigger
party we'll see because yeah like Friday
night they're doing Memento Mori they're
doing which they've already done this
month but they're doing like a special
Halloween edition because they've been
before but then mannequins is also doing
a Friday which is
uh hell Billy like I said it's like a
Rob Zombie like redneck Halloween kind
of theme and then well it's mostly like
Rob Zombie that's what they're doing and
then Saturday night is horrorween you're
supposed to dress like your favorite
horror movie villain and that's they're
gonna do like costume contest because of
that but that's like the Saturday night
but see I'm thinking that
it'd probably be better if we were gonna
party to do Saturday because if we go
Friday I'm not gonna be able to like
have time because we're gonna do the
show and I don't really I'm not gonna
have time to like do the costume you
know what I'm saying whereas Saturday
I'll have like most of the day to [ __ ]
with the costume
because I want the costume to look like
super so what are you telling me you
want to go you want to go to uh
um mannequins on Saturday I just think
that would work out okay we'll do that I
just think that would work out better
because like I said I would like to go
to both but I can't afford it and
probably my liver can't take it and
probably I'll be too tired
no you know what I mean
yeah Ben said uh horror movies in the
50s used to claim they had an ambulance
on standby and paramedics waiting in the
lobby for overcome patrons it's a
[ __ ] publicity stunt I kind of felt
like that too
um you know if they did the same thing
with the Exorcist
um you know they kind of like played up
the tales of like people throwing up and
passing out and then having to take
people out I'm like you'd have to be
very very delicate
too and if you're that delicate why
would you even be going to see that
movie in the first place I'm just not
buying it thank you thank you Jeffy art
what do you say I had a sip of screaming
eagle uh what is that caber caber I
don't know what that is I don't know
what that is two thousand dollars a
bottle one Christmas it tasted no
different than my usual ten dollar one
yeah but I was also wasted so there's
that yeah
that must be wine probably yeah it's not
the wine it's the company yeah I kind of
feel like up to a certain price point
and I think that this has been borne out
by like blind taste tests and stuff up
to a certain price point which is
usually around fifteen twenty dollars
um like after that you're just paying
for the prestige and like the name and
the packaging and stuff like that
because they don't really taste that
much better yeah I I actually mentioned
this on other shows
um
wine tasting is kind of like uh Modern
Art it's a bunch of [ __ ] it's mostly
just about status and uh they like like
she said they did blind taste tests and
see you know they can't really tell the
difference
um yeah that's once wine gets to a
certain right like I said once it's
about 15 bucks a bottle yeah even ten
dollars I've I've had some wine that was
I'm not a wine connoisseur by any means
but I've had some 10 bottle of wines
that were actually pretty good where all
that came from is back in the olden days
there were
there was a lot of difference between
cheap wine and expensive wine this is
going all the way back to the Roman era
and we're not they don't really know
exactly what Romans liked and won they
seem to like sweet wine
um but what it was is that they did not
have
proper bottling techniques and they
couldn't get seals well and
if you bought a shitty brand of wine
back in the olden days chances are
maybe like one out of ten of those
bottles or maybe sometimes more would be
rancid you know it just tastes terrible
and the flavors were always off
it'd be inconsistencies in the same
batch no two bottles tasted the same
after it sat there a little bit because
some bottles were dirtier than others
when they
when they fill them
nowadays if it's down to a science okay
if you were to take somebody from like a
a [ __ ] connoisseur wine tasting
[ __ ] from the 1800s and took
them to Walmart and gave him some of
that [ __ ] cardboard box
I can tell you that was the best wine he
ever had and you're like [ __ ] that's
poor people wanting he's like oh the
poor people are so rich in this era
they're drinking like kings which
there's something to that I mean pretty
much everybody who needs AC has it
uh the average person who's
semi-literate [ __ ] 90 IQ [ __ ]
running around with the phone and the
phone has more power than [ __ ]
a [ __ ] oligarch had in the early
1900s far more you know what I mean
[ __ ]
[ __ ] Howard Hughes could couldn't
have dreamed of that kind of power in
somebody's hand
a cell phone
with access to the internet you know
what I mean so no in in many ways
poverty was eliminated even the [ __ ]
poorest of people here in the United
States are comparatively Rich to what
they were centuries well I mean it's all
relative I mean you're you're always and
that's true of any area you're always
just poor in relation to like other
people other people right which is
better you can play that game forever
that's the same as being ugly or the
same as being short it's always relative
to who's around you you know
so but uh no you can go down to the
projects if you wanted to in Mississippi
and they were living better than a
medieval King
if you see how a medieval king would
live somewhere in Scotland you know if I
could
almost maybe like you know [ __ ] early
medieval period [ __ ] nasty you know
but the point is that nobody had good
[ __ ] nobody had a good [ __ ] because
nobody had invented it yeah right it's
just the standard of living has
increased a lot on the back of [ __ ]
industrial technology
the industrial area they excuse me the
industrial the industrial
um [ __ ] era [ __ ] was a huge boom
to [ __ ] civilization so people just
take it for granted they're spoiled you
know electricity changed the [ __ ]
game indoor plumbing [ __ ] just
running water
climate control
hardwood floors
used to be people just had dirt floors
you know
so you know
ability to [ __ ] wash clothes in your
house even a clothesline it was a good
idea you know they had those I think
going way back but
there were there were certain eras where
entire cities were just nothing but just
infested with lice and there's probably
nothing you can do about it you know
just [ __ ] just so sanitation is just
so much better
Bob Apple says rocking a Creepshow shirt
yeah I know I love this shirt I actually
got this at FYE like at the mall of all
places uh have you checked out the new
series on shutter yes I have
um it's yeah it's good I like it I don't
you know obviously like the you know the
1985 movie is the OG but um you know
it's it's good there were some episodes
of it that I really really liked a lot
um you know let's see uh Anthony says
opinion regarding Cemetery Man I [ __ ]
love Cemetery Man I think you just did
you see it you saw it with me right yeah
it was all right like you thought it was
a little bit weird but it is a little
bit weird but that's okay I really I I
love that movie I think that was a
pretty movie huh the pretty movie
didn't he have like a dead girlfriend
an undead girlfriend yeah kinda it was
yeah
well it wasn't an Italian it was an
Italian film I mean the name of it was
de la morte Delamore yeah it was it was
a good looking movie yeah but I mean the
main actor was Rupert Everett and he's
British but the movie was Italian
ice
but yeah I actually love that movie I
think we reviewed it it was probably
like a while back but yeah we reviewed
it I have it someplace
uh Ben says my dad was a lifelong wine
expert he said really cheap wine it's
usually just as good because they have
Surplus grapes and just use the excess
for producing more of the same under
generic labels see I kind of feel like
that's what happens with a lot of stuff
you know it's like why waste it they're
just laying around right there so
honestly I don't think I've ever had
like I said I'm not a big wine
connoisseur but even like having to do
with liquor and stuff like that even
when you get like the real cheap [ __ ]
it's bad but it's not that bad you know
what I mean
I mean
okay now I will say that a couple times
I've got the well
vodka and stuff like that at
um at ibar like back in the old days
which I think is aristocrat
and
it's not great I mean it mostly just
kind of tastes like rubbing alcohol
but if you mix it with other stuff it's
not too bad but I would rather pay like
a buck or two more and get like
something a little bit better but other
than that like after as long as it's not
like bottom shelf as long as just like
one tear up from that I really can't
tell the difference between
a 12 bottle of vodka for example and a
25 bottle of vodka I can't really tell
the difference
yeah you can only tell you can only
detect the bottom shelf that's yeah
that's what I'm saying so up to a yeah
like after a certain price point I
really can't distinguish them anymore so
it really doesn't seem because honestly
like the most if now if we go to Sam's
I'll get like the Sam's uh Club vodka
which is what 13.99 12.99 something like
that for like a big huge bottle yeah and
that's like Gray Goose it's like a 20
bottle yeah and I can't tell the
difference between that and the 22.99
bottle of Sky which I get if I can't go
to Sam's yeah you know what I mean and I
honestly can't really tell a lot of
difference between that and like an 11
bottle of Pinnacle either I can't tell
the difference between Sam's
um silver tequila and Milagro silver I
think it's the same they're just
identical
and the only difference is the [ __ ]
price
Sam's Silver Tequila is sucking
for that fifth I think it's a
not even fifteen dollars that's cheap
Milagros twice that nearly 30.
for that amount
so that's a good buy actually uh yeah I
think it's twenty dollars twenty dollars
yeah because I remember yeah I remember
you buy it because I remember when we go
to Sam's about 19 something like I
remember the vodka is only I'm pretty
sure the vodka is 13.99 yeah I think is
what it was or maybe just 12.99 and it
comes in a pretty Bottle too it's a
teardrop shape flat the tequila does
yeah it's in a pretty bottle yeah and I
think that's 22 23 yeah and like you
said you can't really tell the
difference I wouldn't know because I'm
not a big two killer fan but you know
like Milagro silver and according to
Khan Watson
he said that Milagro silver is the the
best tequila you can get in Mexico
says they love it well there you go
because what about that exact little
[ __ ] because yeah and then there's my
home brew type you know small family you
know distilleries that make real
expensive [ __ ]
but when he said but when you go to a
nightclub in Mexico and Milagro is their
top shelf that well that's that's the
one they're all like they'll pay more
for that that's the one they'll go to
they're about three or four different
versions of Milagro and here that's the
same thing
yeah Milagro that's going to be one of
that one of the more expensive Club
vodkas yeah
Danny Rowling said Jenny said she
reviewed American World in London would
you ever view the sequel American
Werewolf in Paris which has bad CGI but
still has pretty good practical effects
and original story I might get around to
it one of these days I only saw it one
time and I remember not loving it but
it's been like a while since I've seen
it so
Jeff hard said I love going to liquor
stores to get art and graphic design
ideas yeah that's funny because when we
were at ABC the other day I was just
kind of like I love
um liquor bottles and liquor labels and
stuff like that I really really like the
whole like uh Gestalt of that so
I'm always like really into like looking
at all the different bottle shapes and
all the different the cool [ __ ] they do
with their [ __ ] Toms and glorious
bastards says yeah it's one of the best
ones I believe that that's kind of Aslan
[Laughter]
I'll grow yeah yeah that's good
like I said I wouldn't know I'm not a
big tequila fan but honestly Milagro
silver is really close to nice Vodka
it's mild it mixes with anything
then like they have the uh angio and
then like the gold which is something
you drink on the rocks
like whiskey that's good too but I
noticed the Malaga was more about being
smooth it's got a real smooth flavor to
it not harsh at all it's like Billy
smooth yeah
Anthony said I was flying on a jet six
years ago and realized I was having
drinks at 30 000 feet and come to
understand that a king would not have
this opportunity right see that would
like blow their [ __ ] minds
and I kind of think that's why I try not
to complain too much because
yeah I still complain about stuff but
it's like you know just think about it
in those kind of terms like if you went
back 100 years 200 years man everyone's
life was like so [ __ ] shitty but I
mean they didn't know any better too
it's not like they were like oh look at
those people over there with the
electricity and the Wi-Fi you know what
I mean everybody like had a shitty life
pretty much even I don't think it was
shitty well no but it wasn't well they
wouldn't have realized it was shitty
because there wasn't any because like I
said it's all luxuries and Comforts and
[ __ ] that you'd have they were they were
harder people
well you had to be most of them you had
to be and um even you go back to the
Roman era
they had some [ __ ] that would sound
pretty wild on the surface you know
big public baths
people out there nude sudden bathing and
there was sex going on and you know it
sounded like some wild [ __ ] that you
would see down in some Miami porn flick
or something but if you were to actually
see it it probably was pretty damn
grungy oh yeah I'm sure it was yeah I'm
sure there were just cooties about yeah
it is probably pretty because evidently
sanitation wasn't very even though they
had running Water Sanitation wasn't as
good better than a lot of people have
yeah
the sanitation evidently was not that
good
I still think of like us watching that
show
Spartacus where they had like the public
toilets yeah and they were like all open
and they were just like and then you had
like the one guy who had like the thing
on the end like a stage on the end of it
like a sponge like people can watch it
like they just go under your tank thank
you thank you give them a tip or
whatever yeah it's the same wet sponge
he just [ __ ] washed the other dude's
ass with
for you
and that's they just dropped it at a
bucket away in a bucket that's it that's
aggressive yeah their thinking was not
the same as ours they didn't think
certain things how dirty can butts be
anyway
well we all got them so it must be okay
yeah
I just saw that scene and I was like
yeah that's about right and then like
they had you know you see all that damn
classic statuary that they had and it's
all like a marble a little white looking
and classy and the same thing with a lot
of those buildings the thing is is in
those days they were all painted so it
looked like some tacky
1970s Persian [ __ ] discotheque or
something you know they're [ __ ] tacky
ass you save hell like that's a bad
thing yeah
no those statues would not have looked
good painted but that'd have been super
cool if it had like [ __ ] glitter on
it and [ __ ] like that yeah they tried to
make those statues rhinestones looked
like it was the person standing there
evidently there's faint residues and
pigments like man they probably painted
the pubic hair on them
that sounds like some [ __ ] they would
they have some [ __ ] today that sounds
like some [ __ ] they would do yeah
tacky [ __ ]
well you know I like some tacky thing
Michael says do you guys naturally have
a high tolerance for alcohol
um
I don't I guess I don't know I don't
think it's natural I just think we drink
a lot so it's just
we drink on the show yeah we drink on
the show we drink on the show usually
when you see us drinking that's when we
drink yeah
or when we go out I'm almost immune to
it you know what I mean because I've
[ __ ] got an artificial endocrine
system you know I I don't really ever
pay for it it's not like I don't have to
worry about testosterone suppression
that would normally happen if a dude
drinks he's going to be suppressed as
[ __ ] you know gain all kinds of weight
feel like [ __ ] especially especially at
this age
that's why I go to that biker bar and
those most of those dudes are just all
belly okay
and uh they just they can't they don't
have the they don't have the [ __ ]
hormonal
[ __ ]
content in their blood to fight that
[ __ ] off their their [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] it you know but you know I do
and Jenny gets little bumps here and
there
so it's not the same for us we could
fight that [ __ ] off pretty easily
yeah I don't even usually get hangovers
anymore huh
play like like I said I'll just like
have I'll drink a bottle of water and
then like take three aspirin before I go
to bed and I'm usually fine the next day
I'm like I'm tired but that's about it I
don't have like headaches right you know
I'm all open about my [ __ ] HRT and my
Androgen use right now I'm I'm at the
end part of a [ __ ] Trend stack cycle
I'm I'm [ __ ]
I'm impervious
Trent is and I'm never going to do Trend
again this [ __ ] is [ __ ] bad except
for you cooking that fish last night
that was a little bit what about cooking
the fish drunk last night oh yeah
cushion of cooking a fish I cooked it
though I over seasoned that [ __ ]
I put so much that damn lemon pepper
powder on that [ __ ] lemon pepper
I'm just like man [ __ ] shit's hot
over the shower and then she couldn't
finish hers and I tasted it and hers was
[ __ ] seasoned about twice what mine
was yeah I just was like working real
fast just put a whole bunch on there
yeah
but uh man I'm [ __ ] um
I've had this [ __ ] my system is building
up I got about a week left last night I
was crying like a [ __ ] in [ __ ] bed
and [ __ ] just my I was at my wits
[ __ ] end I could not sleep I hate
when that I just couldn't sleep I
started getting frustrated and my
[ __ ] hormones were all out of bounds
I just they're going
you know like in [ __ ] tears come into
my eyes I was [ __ ] so frustrated that
I couldn't sleep
finally like 5 30 I fell asleep
I just I angered myself to sleep I hate
when that happened well because I
haven't it hasn't happened like lately I
mean I don't sleep a lot anyway like I
last night I think I fell asleep at like
11 30 or something and then I woke up
um I woke up at like three-ish because I
had to go to the bathroom and then but
sometimes like if I wake up in the
middle of night to pee which I always do
now
um then when I get back in bed I can't
go back to sleep and then I'll lay there
for hours and hours and I'm just getting
more and more mad because I'm just kind
of like God [ __ ] damn it because I
know that even if I fall asleep I'm
gonna wake up at like 6 30 or 7 and not
be able to fall back to sleep so
you know because once it's daylight out
I can't get back to sleep that's just
how I work
you know what I mean
that last time I went to a club
vegan black metal Chef was there Brian
he lifts too he's a natural though he
doesn't take anything he's trying to do
his [ __ ] vegan too he's not getting big
just saying just saying bribe you're not
getting big dude
anyway he looks at me because dude man
you're looking freaky as [ __ ] you know
because because it was a pretty dramatic
change once it started to work on me and
I was thinking to myself when I started
I was about
189 and I said man I must be [ __ ]
pushing 200 pounds now because I [ __ ]
feeling [ __ ] huge man [ __ ] people
were like God
people that knew me
but I hadn't checked the scale
two days ago I said I'm gonna get that
scale out so watch man would be like 200
[ __ ] pounds
[ __ ] took all my clothes off and [ __ ]
and got on there 172. I lost weight yeah
I lost weight
well you must have like lost mostly fat
then because muscle is generally like
more heavy than it recalled yeah it it
ate all that damn fat in between the
muscle fibers yeah and then I gained
some muscle but after it all worked out
to 172. you know
but my strength went up a lot you know
I'm a lot stronger and I feel more dense
like I'm more compact or something
like a pound cake yeah
but I got a week left on it man and it's
just getting worse
every few days it's just like it's just
piling up and you just get to where you
just can't sleep you're just too alert
you're tired but you just don't sleep
but you grow anyway it's weird you get
stronger anyway
but um God I hate not being able to
sleep right here yeah but then I'm
coming off of this and I'm I'm not going
to do this one again man yeah most dudes
only do this maybe once a year but I'm
like I think I'd rather there's other
[ __ ] there's a lot
easier to deal with you know I mean it's
more expensive it takes a little bit
longer but I got time there's no I don't
think it it would all this would only
help a dude who's trying to make some
kind of show date he's a [ __ ] ifbb
Pro and he's got to beat these other
guys they're in a steroid drag race
basically to [ __ ] who's gonna look
the freakiest by a certain date then
yeah you probably it might give you an
edge but just a regular civilian type
gym rat dude like me uh nah Winstrol
wind strong testosterone that's good
enough well-known [ __ ]
I'm gonna read Michael's comment because
I Think You're gonna laugh he said this
thought just came in my head not a put
down and you guys are cool but I can't
picture you guys being intimate
I thought I would just read that out
loud it's because I thought that was
funny and I thought you would probably
have a comment about that
[Laughter]
really you don't have anything to say
about it you don't have anything to say
about that man out bounce Jenny all
around it
I like your sound back in the day she'd
[ __ ] enjoy it now she's like will you
hurry up
Sleep God damn it [ __ ] is old yeah
go get you another girlfriend
I didn't say that but you kind of hated
it again get somebody to take up some of
this Slack
especially with like it you're on cycle
your sex drives way up
yeah which is fine but you know she got
sick of that well sometimes I have other
things I gotta do like I gotta work and
stuff
that's all I mean
my HRT is not really HRT so sometimes
I'm doing [ __ ] 400 500 milligrams of
test that might be a week which that's
probably [ __ ] 1600 nanograms per
deciliter that's like three times what a
20 year old has and then
and then if you're doing anabolics on
top of that [ __ ] effectively it
doesn't anabolics are a lot it's a lot
more forgiving it's more targeted and to
the Androgen receptors that are for
muscle building but it does other [ __ ]
too
it would be kind of like effectively
like having [ __ ] 3 000 nanograms per
deciliter probably in your body which
would be like [ __ ] seven or eight
times what a [ __ ]
optimal [ __ ] 20 year old would have
it's a super physiological level so this
is a supernatural [ __ ]
you can go out there and work yourself
out to the Bone and you're totally
healed up 12 hours later
a normal human can't do that
would take a week to heal up especially
at 50. you could never do it in your 50s
no
you guys see [ __ ] Dwayne Johnson The
Rock and all those guys don't even for
one second [ __ ] it don't even don't you
even Dare for one second think that
those dudes are natural no [ __ ] way
I'm sure nobody thinks no [ __ ] way
you cannot look like that at 50
something or 40 something you can't look
like that barely in your mid-30s well I
think that's true of any celebrity right
whether they're bodybuilders or whether
they're like beautiful women or whatever
yeah they're all on stuff to help them
look that like that I mean yeah that's
kind of the whole point yeah and it's
not cheating if you just let [ __ ] go
then you're not gonna look that way
sorry it's not really cheating because
if you see how that stuff works it's
working by biological rules they're just
making sure that they're playing by
those rules they're taking that win
straw or they're gonna take this [ __ ]
hormone and this and that and it's the
same way if your [ __ ] teeth fall out
you're gonna put [ __ ] false teeth in
if you [ __ ] go blind you're gonna get
[ __ ] glasses you know it's it's it's
that same philosophy
um as you get older you can't [ __ ]
keep that hormonal production up up so
you're gonna have to inject it
and it works they've been doing it since
the 1930s
every one of those dudes that were
[ __ ] jacked back in the [ __ ] 40s
and [ __ ] and 50s none of those dudes are
natural
they had anabolics and testosterone back
then
it's just that most people didn't know
about it
Michael said you're both attractive by
the way
hey Casey meant to imply something else
I didn't think that but you know thank
you for saying that we have porn you see
our porn you [ __ ] you know you'd
understand it
you just never published it
oh my goodness Jenny throwing me around
a room about a dick [ __ ] all kinds of
[ __ ]
just like Pookie throws her toys around
sure slapping me
that's your head's bald I could like
slap slap your bald head yes because it
make a cool noise then
you're a tiny little booty yeah
um monkey booty this is just [ __ ] you
do have a little monkey booty actually
yeah coming at you like a gibbon
well it's not well I don't know if I go
that far it's not like bright red or
anything but I think a gibbon he's like
presenting that's like
that's super funny
uh Thomas and glorious bastards just
said well just pictured Kirk making love
to spock well like I said that's a whole
that's a whole sub-genre of fanfic right
you got horn for that they yeah they got
porn of everything yeah but there
there's a lot of porn of that yeah
there's a lot of porn of that
funnily enough I was just watching
um
my six episodes of Thriller earlier and
there was one episode in there that had
the chat in it when he was young from
1960 or 1961. it was actually the best
episode that I've seen so far because it
was actually very horrory
horrorary
because you know Thriller like I've been
talking about it's mostly like a crime
show but they have like a bunch of
horror stuff on there too Jeffy Hart
said when it comes to testosterone
regimen oh this is going to go on for a
while okay what starter beginner routine
or brand does Tom recommend I don't lift
a ton of weight but I do low hot reps
should I change my routine first of all
how old are you
I had to know how old you are
and whether or not you're on HRT I'm not
sure exactly what he's asking what is he
asking read that again to me when it
comes to testosterone regimen what
starter or beginner routine or brand
does Tom recommend I don't lift a ton of
weight
but I do low hot reps should I change my
routine well I don't know instead he's
43 43.
I have 43 if you if you want to put on
any weight
uh in terms of muscle and get rid of a
lot of fat you have to be on HRT hormone
replacement therapy I don't know what
country you live in some places like
Mexico which are very civilized places
you can just get [ __ ] testosterone
over the counter like in a civilized
[ __ ] country I kind of wish they
would do that here actually most of the
[ __ ] you can get over the counter in
Mexico I wish they would sell over the
yeah but you see [ __ ] our Elites here
have the [ __ ] medical industry
totally locked up they want their cut
all right they have to make their offer
something that you should be able to
just go and buy okay and it's not
expensive
so
I'm not a doctor
okay
but I have a bricklayer remember the
[ __ ]
bones and I'm a doctor I'm not a prickly
anyway uh also he said he lives in
Florida he lives in Florida okay
all right if what you can do is you can
just go on Google go HRT clinic near me
and this [ __ ] will pop up
it'll be a clinic near you
you go in there for a consultation tell
them that you got [ __ ] that you uh
that you that you want [ __ ] HRT you
want testosterone you want to lose fat
and gain some muscle
you'll go in there and you'll pay about
700 for that first month it's going to
involve consultations [ __ ] blood work
and then your first month of the drugs
that they're gonna give you
all drugs they're not with drugs they're
just hormones all right well it's you
know that's what your body would
normally make anyway
it's all right they're gonna probably
put you on 200 milligrams of
testosterone a week you inject it you
got to learn you're gonna learn how to
inject it to yourself they're going to
give you the rigs and everything
and then I'm probably going to give you
1000 IU 1000 IU of HCG all right which
is something to keep you from Shoot keep
you shooting live rounds it's pituitary
gland
as they said keep you shooting live
rounds okay I just got a message that
something got delivered oh okay now if
you don't want to shoot live rounds you
can just take you can just take tests
and it'll shut down and it'll be like
birth control for on on a female okay
because if your test is is real high
naturally now excuse me if your test is
real high because you're injecting it
your system will see that in there and
go well we don't need to make tests we
got a whole lot so your nuts will just
go to sleep you get a little tiny
peanuts you know little peanuts little
sleeping yeah
it'll be a long time for those suckers
to come back too if it's on their own
all right
now
ACG will keep them going
all right so you have decent balls okay
and you need decent balls yeah if you
got if you're at a cheaper clinic
they'll give you Clomid there's a little
Clomid pills which kind of does the same
thing it just it's a different it just
kind of does it from a different in a
different way
Columbus a lot cheaper I like HCG it's
better
uh Coleman can kind of give you a funny
feeling after a while
and HCG helps keep weight off and it
also helps you HCG I noticed that it
stimulates all the other glands because
it stimulates the pituitary gland which
is like the master gland to tell all the
other ones to keep going and I noticed
that HCG got rid of my heartburn I can
eat anything like I was a kid lucky
after that you know if I can never get a
sour stomach never get heartburned
wow I wish I could find something that
did that for me because yeah I've never
found anything HCG would do it I've even
bought I've I bought all the medicines I
bought all that kind of stuff the thing
is though is that I've already offered
you that kind of [ __ ] and it says no you
will become fertile again you'll start
ovulating you'll go in there and all
that [ __ ] comes not worth it
not worth it so
the uh take that
and then uh weight will start you'll get
stronger weight will start coming off
you a lot easier and uh in terms of fat
and uh muscle will go on now
because you're on HRT you don't have to
worry about testosterone suppression
anymore so you drink
you know it doesn't matter you could
even go without sleep still doesn't
matter you're still going to have all
that testosterone and then you'll still
be growing
um you just kind of overcome it makes
you real resilient
and because you had to worry about
testosterone suppression that's a
Gateway into effective steroids
because the main the main negative side
effect of steroids is testosterone
suppression you take tests you take
steroids your test will shut down
which that's not a problem you can wake
it back up if you know what to do but
back in the day dudes would take
steroids and come off of them and get
fat as [ __ ] and go what happened well
you didn't get back on HCG to start your
nuts [ __ ] running again and you
didn't use Clomid to recover it's called
PCT post a little therapy Factory right
so they didn't know about PCT you know
Pros did but just the [ __ ] high
school high school [ __ ] athletes and
[ __ ] they didn't know what the [ __ ] they
were doing and they would just [ __ ]
jump on and off steroids like you could
do that you can't
not really
you come off steroids you're gonna have
to [ __ ] do Post Cycle Therapy
to get your injury consistent running
again to maintain what it is that you
build and if you built a [ __ ] ton of
muscle normal endogenous testosterone
Pro production will not maintain that
amount of muscle so it means you're
going to have to be on HRT
which is better than more than natural
production that'll that'll hold that
muscle on there
not your own endogenous production
especially after 35 after 35 you're
washed up you've got to be on HRT
everybody starts going downhill yeah
you're starting to go down here Camp guy
said they say that old married dudes
have higher sperm counts than young
single dudes no I have heard that though
I have heard that also yeah maybe
they're not jerking off as much young
dudes are probably [ __ ] into porn
that's probably what it is
uh Jeffy art said I've considered that
as well I'm way too much of a [ __ ] to
inject myself with anything though all
right so uh and then Jeff here I'd say
Jenny I just look at cake and cookies
and I gain weight I feel your pain yeah
same same it's really sucky I really
don't I really wish I could be one of
those people that could just like eat as
much as they wanted and like not gain
weight but I'm unfortunately not one of
those people
uh Michael said why did Tom have to take
testosterone therapy again huh why did
you have to take testosterone therapy
again I got old yeah yeah
if you're a man and you want to remain a
man after 35 and you start considering
[ __ ] HRT
sorry at 40 knowing what I know know now
I would have gone under 40.
all right it would have been a lot
smoother transition into midlife
um
you have no idea
what a dude on HRT who's keeping up with
himself what he looks like in his 70s
a
a dude on HRT who's keeping up with
himself maybe doing a little bit of
anabolics here or there but he's not an
IBB Pro he's not trying to [ __ ] weigh
270 pounds he's just trying to remain
fit
will look better than I do at 73. I got
video [ __ ] evidence of this you look
at the dude
his body looks like a [ __ ] an A-Class
body of a [ __ ] 25 year old the face
will kind of look like a
the guy in his early 50s and the
[ __ ] mid 70s
now you start pushing it too far you're
weighing 260 pounds 240 pounds
on a small or a medium frame even a
large frame doesn't matter
your heart was not designed to pump that
pump blood through that many blood
vessels that's a lot of stress on your
heart it [ __ ] your valves up
the compounds themselves are safe
what's dangerous is all that [ __ ]
muscle mass that's a lot of muscle mass
and the heart was never designed to push
blood through that much muscle
and those when it's beaten it'll be
strong
because those anabolics have
strengthened that heart
but the valves are kind of like made out
of plasticky cartilage type [ __ ] that
[ __ ] starts flexing and it's all [ __ ]
a lot of stress and it'll wear out
to happen to Arnold they had to replace
well in some ways too it's like I'm not
saying it's good to be like fat but in
some ways
um a person that's like you know 300
pounds fat as opposed to somebody that
is 300 pounds of muscle yeah oh yeah big
difference Yeah it's you're gonna have
problems in both situations but in some
ways it might be better better be fat
yeah than than muscular because that fat
doesn't have all those blood vessels in
it right all right and you're not and
you're not pumping it's not very oxygen
hungry fat isn't yeah that muscle
has to all it all needs oxygen-rich
blood
and there's a lot of blood vessels there
and that's a lot of stress on the heart
you really don't want to go
too much above you know 230 Maybe
probably about 230 240. now I'm talking
about if you're super lean I'm talking
about dudes that are [ __ ] lower than
15 body fat
in other words abs
abs and [ __ ] cut and you're 230
pounds that motherfucker's big you know
that's a lot of [ __ ] that's a lot of
weight for somebody that has no fat on
them
there's a lot of stress on the heart now
there's some caveats
if you look like that at 18
and Main try to maintain that your whole
life that's a lot of stress
but if you're trying to look at that
like that after 50 it's not as bad
because
as long as you were natural and you
weren't doing a lot of anabolics and a
lot of [ __ ] hormones Before 40 or 50
you're you've got a lot of gas in your
tank you
you probably haven't been under a lot of
stress
so you can handle another 30 years
you know of life being kind of jacked
because you're going to meet
age ex you know maximum life expectancy
or life expectancy anyway in 20
something years
you know
if anything it might extend your life
because you're doing it in the second
half not in the first half
you know you don't need it as much in
the first half
you need it more when you start to age
after 40 your body's shutting down
you're dying basically you're you're a
program to just shut down and die it's
been a long Pro but gonna be a long
process though where you can kind of
bypass that and [ __ ] make those
systems wake back up you're you're in
endocrine system really shouldn't be
shutting down there's no reason for it
to do it it's just that you weren't
selectively bred
for a long life you know I mean most of
your ancestors had already reproduced by
18 or 19 going back [ __ ] thousands
and thousands of years so that was never
really bred into you
to live to be 130 you know
Kenny Rowling said we should play with
the Ouija board on this episode
well like I said I do have a I do have
the mouse pad right here that's like a
Ouija board
yeah Ben said hit that like button
people I'm gonna run to the bathroom
and then when I get back maybe it's time
for another drink
oh my God it's so light outside yeah
it's still early
thank you
cam guy said he'd rather have
liposuction
nah
liposuction is [ __ ] expensive man
it's [ __ ] easier just to go ahead and
just inject tests
so much easier
turn your
turn your metabolism back on
you'll start
burning food and metabolizing like you
were even better we really in my case
better than when I was a teenager
there's nothing magic about it it's all
sides it's just
now you're able to signal
all the sales can now communicate and
send signals to one another better
it's not cheating you're actually
following the rules when you do that
none of it none of it is violating any
of the the rules of your biology
if it was violating the rules of biology
it wouldn't work
it works because that's the way the Body
Works
you're just exploiting some of the
features that are in there
campaign has between 175 and 190 all my
life and now I'm 234 pounds bummer yeah
you fat bro
fat
okay yeah he said
how old how old are you
okay
telling you easy this shit's easy to
take care of it's just you got to get
the biology you got to get the chemistry
correct you know
put some testosterone in there all that
[ __ ] will start reversing
see that light has been that color for
like a really long time it's just it
randomly changes yeah back to that one
other color and I can't figure out why
yeah it was funny because like uh
my boy was on here says well I'm aging
normally and I goes yeah I noticed
Asian normally Amanda sucks [ __ ]
you're not such a [ __ ] Tom what's up
I'm a [ __ ] yeah I was Asian normally if
you see the picture of me I'm [ __ ] 53
I'm going on 54. if you were to see a
theoretical a picture of what I would
have looked like without HRT you'd be
laughing I'd have been [ __ ] skinny uh
with a fat pot belly and uh face [ __ ]
up that's what it looked like you just
you just can't maintain
uh you can't maintain health or physique
through natural aging
natural aging means you get weak and die
that's what that means
we're raging against the dying yes like
Dylan Thomas said you're genetically
just you're genetically designed to
[ __ ] self-destruct you know so you
want to get around that
[Laughter]
trying to bypass them
most of the destruction is [ __ ]
hormone starvation
your body doesn't work
it's not working right HCG and test
that's the foundation right there for a
man
you might want to throw in a little test
but a small amount
and probably something like progesterone
Prima Bowen something like that
what are the dudes at Benny Hill bald
head slap yeah
should I slap your bald head no I ain't
worried about that you're not worried
about not worry about any [ __ ] I
can't let me uh try to get you one of
these time for another drink time for
another drink Friday night I'm kind of I
mean I like going out but
kind of glad we're not going out tonight
because
it's just kind of like a lot to do the
show and then
I gotta get ready and then we gotta go
out and then it's like really late and
then you know then I'm like really
sleepy when I get home
so you know
like I said we'll probably stay in this
weekend because of all the Halloween
parties next weekend we gotta save up
for that kind of [ __ ] and like I said I
gotta I gotta practice my costume I
gotta practice I think it's gonna be
okay but see that's what I thought
I always like have a picture in my head
it's like this is how I'm gonna do it
and I have it all like
plotted out in my head so sometimes I'm
like well because I have it plotted out
my head that I don't have to do it in
actuality and then when I actually start
doing it doesn't work out the way that I
thought that it would and then I'm like
well [ __ ] now I don't have time to like
fix it but I think it'll be okay I think
it'll be okay
and like I said I got most of the major
stuff but there's two things that I hope
I get in time but if I don't it's not
that big of a deal you know what I mean
it'll still look cool without that but
we'll see
we'll see I think it's gonna look cool
but we'll find out we'll find out you
guys should we'll see it on actual
Halloween
what should we do like for because
actual Halloween is on Monday right and
that's not this Monday but like the next
Monday and that's
um our haunting show
so should we do like a haunting episode
and also a Halloween special
Maybe
I don't know I don't know I'm not
worried about it
well yeah I mean I'm the one that got to
worry about it I ain't worried about it
I gotta tie my shoe
he's only worried about like worried
about [ __ ] that's happened right [ __ ] is
happening right now I got a tie my shoe
um no but just do a hunting episode
that's all Oscar said scrap The Haunting
show all together
why well the thing about it is that we
still need some [ __ ] to talk about yeah
and so but like I said we could maybe do
like a haunting episode plus like I said
just Halloween let me just do a
Halloween theme a show for a honey
that's what I was kind of thinking but I
was like well is do any of them have
anything to do with Halloween there's
got to be at least one yeah
right there's got to be
maybe we could do like the silly mummy
one yeah
yeah we just kind of like
we can Goof on that one I swear to God
some of the newer ones are they're troll
I'm pretty sure they were trolling which
if they did like that was a that was a
successful troll because they actually
got on TV and if they were I actually
like admire their ability to keep a
straight face because I would not have
anything we could do that we'll do them
I have not been able to yeah but like I
said we can do other because I'm sure
like we'll probably have like
trick-or-treaters coming and we'll have
to like run down and answer the door and
[ __ ] like that but
I don't think we haven't bought any
candy have we oh no
probably wait till the last minute
because otherwise I'm otherwise I'll eat
it all yeah before look at Pookie's
[ __ ] Action Kitty foes what's she
doing look at that [ __ ]
one back foot yeah like you get getting
ready to spring forward huh that's what
I call her launching position yeah she's
getting ready she's so funny because she
she'll lay down and like her little then
her put she'll put her back legs like
straight out Tom said she looks like a
seal he's like a seal yeah and then we
were like she was doing that before the
show when we were both looking at her
and then she was looking at both of us
like what am I doing something wrong why
are you guys been staring at me because
we were like talking to her she's like
she thinks if we're both looking at her
that she's doing something bad then
she's not supposed to be doing
laughs
all right so if you guys have any
questions if uh you want or anything you
wanted us to talk about
in terms of uh episodes from the past or
any questions about any cases we can run
through that uh we can do any kind of
current events or whatever
just see what's out there or Ben saying
he's on a seventh floor apartment so I
can't do Halloween treats for children
children okay yeah
yeah I mean we had how many did we have
last year it's um not a whole lot
because we were here for Halloween last
year but we hadn't been in the house for
that long yeah
but I don't know we'll see how it goes
there are this is a big neighborhood and
I kind of feel like we'll probably get a
lot of trick-or-treaters but I can't
believe we've been here for a year I
can't believe that either it like went
by so quick because it seems like
we still have so much [ __ ] to do in this
house that's what I mean it just seems
like we just [ __ ] it's like we don't
even have [ __ ] Furniture in half the
rooms because it's like we should be
repainted because I didn't really like
the colors but I want to put Furniture
in because I said well I gotta paint
these I gotta paint these walls that's
what I mean it's like you don't wanna I
mean that's why I came and painted this
room like before I moved everything in
here because I didn't want to have to
like move [ __ ] you know what I mean but
this is really the only room that got
painted this in my bathroom
the rest of it we just didn't [ __ ]
bother
I don't know I'm looking for I'm looking
forward to Halloween though I love
Halloween it's my favorite [ __ ]
holiday
I'm so excited about my costume I hope
it comes out good
I'll be really really sad I'm
heartbroken if it doesn't come out the
way I'm imagining but
they usually don't
what do you mean costumes don't usually
come out the way you're thinking that
they do yeah
then you have to work on them and then
you know what I mean they're kind of
like well I tend to see I have to see
what it is
I know what the costume is don't tell
anybody I ain't saying anything you know
I don't know how that's going to turn
out but you have to see
I can tell that you're dubious and I'm
dubious
that's a difficult one
it's not it'll be fine I don't know I
know what I'm doing all right I know
what I'm doing
I think yeah
I think I know what I'm doing okay have
a little have a little faith in me all
right we'll see
this is why I don't like to like tell
them about my plants and stuff like that
because he always like shits on them I
don't [ __ ] on him just saying that's a
hard one
it's not it'll be fine it'll be fine
it'll be fine
uh let's see uh I teach you the
animation department at a community
college said Jeffy art one of my
students wants me to cosplay as a
character he designed for his Capstone
project yeah but like would anybody know
what that was though
and I mean I'm a big advocate of I'm I
like doing I mean I will admit that my
costume this year is not that obscure I
mean well it's not obscure at all really
but it was just all I could think and I
was just like man I've been wanting to
do this one for a while so I'm gonna do
it but
the costume that I was thinking of that
I didn't end up doing
um but maybe I'll get one day as a
backup because it'd probably be cheap
was you guys remember the 70s movie
um Alice Sweet Alice do you remember the
killer in that yeah like with the clear
yeah the mask and like the yellow
raincoat and stuff I said well that
might be a good backup costume to have
because you'd really only need like the
mask and the raincoat and maybe like a
fake knife or something but how many
people would know what that was though
but then I was like surprised because
then I looked it up and there was like a
whole website that had all of these like
you know movie like horror movie related
costumes and that was on there even
though that was probably the most
obscure horror movie that was on there
to be honest because I was like I don't
I'm not a big fan of like people that
because you remember when like it
chapter one came out and it chapter 2
came out everybody was like dressing up
as Pennywise for Christ's sake and it's
like that's a cool costume and
everything but Jesus Christ everyone's
doing that everybody
so I don't know I I like something
that's like not so obscure that
everybody's like what the [ __ ] is that
but
not so
you know not so common that everybody's
gonna be dressed like that
you know what I mean
so I don't know like not like you know
how everybody was like Harley Quinn that
year and like
everybody's clowns and it's just kind of
I don't know that's just kind of lame
it's like not very imaginable yeah only
half the Harley Quinns had the visual
impact of [ __ ] Harley Quinn if you
asked me the ones that I saw
I'm just not I'm not a big you've got
enough to wear that to wear that well
that too it's like yeah it depends on
the person wearing it you know what I
mean yeah
it's just there's two different ones the
one from the movie and the one from the
from the uh right from the animated one
the one that actually looks like a
harlequin
uh they're both good costumes
everybody yeah does that yeah everybody
yeah and if you're gonna do if you're
gonna do the movie version well either
one of those versions you know I've seen
okay
I've only seen
I've only seen when it comes to the
movie version what was that what was
that [ __ ] actress's name the one that
was from that's Margaret Margaret yeah I
love her she's great
I've seen girls that have that build
that they can pull it off
I've also seen girls that have a [ __ ]
like a hot thick look can pull that off
that that outfit also looks good with
booty and [ __ ] you know DNA that looks
good too
um the harder one though is the uh the
animated one
with the little
yeah yeah I know you're talking the
little mask a little Jester cap looking
thing and she had
and you gotta be
thin and athletic with good muscle on
you to replicate the way that cartoon
looked and small you know you're talking
a five foot woman usually has those
proportions you taller girls don't have
that
um it's a kind of a short and trim
muscular legs kind of look in other
words like a gymnast
a gymnast type build
and I've seen girls cosplay that and the
ones that really pull it off kind of
have that gym this build well because it
looks more like like that cartoon the
cartoon character right because the way
she's drawn I mean you could if you were
a different size you could do it but
you'd have to modify it in a way that
would like look good on you I feel like
and it wouldn't look as authentic when
you look like that cartoon right which
like I said is fine if you want to do
like a variation of it but I'm just I
don't know when it comes to all those
costumes and superheroes and [ __ ] you
have to pick one that is that fits your
body style
or the effect is not the same
I was talking to my friend Jen other
when we were out the other night and
because we were talking about Halloween
and I was like
I don't know I'm kind of like one
whenever I'm going to look for like
costumes because I don't usually I don't
like to buy like a ready-made costume
because I kind of feel like that's
cheating a little bit
um I mean unless you're gonna pay like a
couple hundred dollars for like a really
really good one like a deluxe one like I
kind of feel like it's cheating and you
should probably just like make it out of
your own you don't have to sew it or
anything like that but like put it
together out of your own [ __ ] you know
what I mean so uh so we were talking
about that and I said I honestly when I
look at costume stores if I go to Spirit
Halloween or whatever it's like I kind
of at least look at the men's costumes
because
if you go and look at just women's
costume then it's just gonna be sexy
this sexy that like every single thing
it's like can I just have like a normal
Freddy Krueger costume does it have to
be like sexy Freddy Krieger I'm like
that's [ __ ] up
um you know what I mean like a little
bit like if you want to be sexy Freddy
Krueger fine but it's like I don't even
want to be sexy Freddy Krueger I guess
so but it's like that just seems like a
weird combo to me because if you wanted
to be Freddy Freddy Krueger but you're a
girl
to get I would rather just look like
regular Freddy Krueger yeah like scary
or I don't want to be sexy Freddy
Krueger that's dumb
that whole concept is dumb the regular
Freddy Krueger outfits are available for
the guys and a woman can wear that
that's all that is
yeah that's what I'm saying I would
rather just get the men's version yeah
because I think it's stupid to be sexy
Freddy Krueger
I understand that's a stupid idea I
understand it but it's just funny that I
mean it's gotten so bad that you
literally you can find like a sexy
version of like pretty much any costume
you want even like really really stupid
ones sexy uh Human Centipede
I'm you know what I think I've seen one
of those I think I've seen one of those
seriously you do it I mean well you
probably don't want to Google that
phrase because who knows what'll come up
but I'm just saying like some of this
stuff I don't know it just seems like
really really funny to me because I was
telling Jen I was like look it's like my
whole thing I have a very small window
of stuff that I like
uh Halloween costumes to be it's like
you want to look
I mean you kind of want to look kind of
hot and sexy but you all it's like I
I would rather like I want to look like
a monster you know what I mean I like
looking like and I've been like that
since I was a kid like because I knew
like other little girls and stuff like
that there was like I want to be a
princess and so I was like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I want to be like I want to be like
a [ __ ] up I always wanted to be like a
hag or a mummy or something like that I
always wanted to look scary I want to
look scary like if you you can look hot
at the same time but scary is always is
always going to be like the main concern
I want to look scary like a monster I
don't necessarily want to look hot but
that but if you can also look hot and
look like [ __ ] up and scary like a
monster at the same time then that's
good too but I would rather look scary
and I've always been like that because I
was like it's Halloween
I don't want to just go around like
looking like like the lamest girls
costume ever it's like look I'm a cat
like they put like little black cat ears
on and like a little [ __ ] leotard or
whatever I'm like Danny Danny says the
rock took his vitamins and said his
prayers just like Hulk Hogan did yeah
yeah I think it's what I think is funny
what I thought I always thought was
funny is that people who would not
accept it just could not accept that
Arnold Schwarzenegger did did steroids
why are people so invested in like
whether other people do steroids or not
uh back in the day
I mean who cares
well really back in the day in the 70s
it people didn't really understand what
was going on they thought if well
steroids you just take steroids you get
big
you know no you got to lift weight a lot
of it and the steroids allows you to
lift more and more weights more often
you can work out every day instead of
only two times a week so you got to do
that work nothing will happen if you
just take them you know uh it depends on
which ones you're doing you know some
are about endurance or whatever fat loss
but
no so
back in the golden era in the 70s
the Arnold and [ __ ] Sly and
Frank Zane although he claimed to be
natural I don't [ __ ] believe it
they wouldn't come out about their
[ __ ] use
because they thought that that would
undercut their work in the eye of the
public you know I mean oh they'll just
think that you just sit around and take
the stairs and get big no you gotta
[ __ ] work
and they were banned out of pro sports
so there was this idea that they were
illegal they weren't illegal you can get
them you can get them back then and they
were legal in California for a long time
and you can still get them today you
just got to get them prescribed to you
and I don't know it depends state by
state you know certain [ __ ] Florida
has the most liberal
[ __ ]
regulations on that you can get anything
here
um you can go to HRT clinic and get
[ __ ] all kinds of cool [ __ ]
so
um the public was kind of brainwashed
into thinking that they were somehow
illicit or that it was cheating it was
no it's just performance enhancement
and here's the thing all their [ __ ]
um football players and all their pro
athletes and [ __ ] that they were
worshiping on television it doesn't
matter [ __ ] what sport it was I would
say even baseball they were all using
all of them
they're just using different things
and they used them in the training
season
to get stronger get bigger and when the
games would start they'd come off all
that stuff they knew how to come off of
it without [ __ ] getting fat and [ __ ]
and then they go take their drug test
and they played the game not on not on
junk
but they were taken but when they were
training they were on steroids
and that that applies to the [ __ ]
Olympics
those little [ __ ] 12 and 13 year old
[ __ ] gymnast girls with those big old
[ __ ] square legs their [ __ ] four
foot ten doing all those [ __ ]
cartwheels and [ __ ] you think that they
weren't on Prima bowling they're on
[ __ ] Primo
those girls are 12 10.
they weren't on Primo for the event
they'd been off for a couple weeks but
when they were training they were on all
that stuff
so it's just it's just Rife with it
people got to grow up and understand
that the Technology's been out for
[ __ ] 100 years and they're using it
that's all
like I said I'm pretty sure nobody cares
nobody cares anymore I don't think that
much it's just part of modern technology
well that's what I mean biotech
everybody's doing something um
you know
yeah it's just biotech
half y'all supposed to be dead anyway
insulin keeping you alive
[ __ ] medical procedures pills
well you're supposed to is that cheating
yeah it's cheating come off all that
[ __ ] let's see you drop dead you know
you're not gonna do that
I mean why would you want to do that
anyway because yeah we're like what do
you want to go back to the [ __ ]
Middle Ages when people died when they
were [ __ ] 35 from easily preventable
injections take your [ __ ] false
that's not cool take your [ __ ] false
teeth out and throw them away don't you
[ __ ] reading glasses away
[Laughter]
you cheat yeah I can do that but
everything will just be a big blur I
won't be able to see any of your like
chats or pull all those [ __ ] cat pull
all those [ __ ] um fillings out of
your teeth that's cheat
yeah I mean there comes a point where
yeah
stop using toilet paper that's cheating
you should be wiping with your hand
toilet paper is not natural
somebody said earlier it's like oh
remember like back in the 21st century
when everybody was just using paper to
wipe their asses
shells like the [ __ ] yeah they're
talking about yeah the three shells yeah
he knows what he's talking about
got another Demolition Man the
Demolition Man was prophetic [ __ ] that
was a prophetic movie three shells yeah
Linux Warrior says uh the bobert MTG
crew are coming for Halloween this year
Christian nationalist evangelicals are
not having it they need to go back to
the [ __ ] 80s where they belong
actually no they need to [ __ ] off this
planet and go like get launched into the
sun where they actually belong I don't
really know they can come take my
[ __ ] Halloween when they pry it for
my cold dead fingers okay sorry and you
know what I mean Halloween is like the
second biggest holiday how much do
people in America spend on Halloween
several billion dollars every single
year that shit's not going anywhere
y'all like they can cry about it all
they want like oh it's evil and [ __ ]
like that that's all LARPing man those
people don't believe that [ __ ]
well they you know they know that
there's some like toothless Hicks like
back in the [ __ ] uh some trailer park
somewhere that believes it so that's why
they're saying it I don't even believe
that they do
all those toothless Hicks are bad that
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're all down who the
[ __ ] doesn't work
titties I don't trust anybody that
doesn't like Halloween
I don't trust anybody that doesn't like
what the [ __ ] is the matter with you if
you don't like Halloween no they're
tripping well what that is first did you
see that I was reading this article the
other day about this crazy old this
crazy one well she wasn't old but she
was probably like younger than me which
is scary but she was like uh going on
and about on about uh Hocus Pocus 2
um and how that was on the Disney on
Disney Plus or whatever and how that's
like you know uh luring kids into
Satanism or whatever I'm like oh my God
it's like the [ __ ] 80s did we learn
we learned nothing did we learn nothing
still this is like the 21st century [ __ ]
off with that Jesus Christ yeah that
wasn't about anything even back then
Jesus Christ yeah that's what I mean it
was a bunch of crap even back then yeah
that wasn't anything about that yeah
there wasn't very many of those people
and they put them on television to
magnify the [ __ ] platform and it
spread
to like your parents and maybe they
thought there was something to it you
know maybe we should get rid of these
Motley Crew albums but they weren't
paying attention they were [ __ ] eat
people are easy to panic you can Panic
people very easily you know they're
doing it now you know with all about all
kinds of things you know people are
easily controlled by fear but it's not
Pokey it erases their ability to think
so no whenever the [ __ ]
mass media comes at you with a [ __ ]
fear it's always to just to manipulate
you you don't believe them it's all
propaganda
and all that [ __ ] was propaganda it's
just a means of control
just that the people that owned the
country weren't sure if they were going
to use the right or the left as a means
of control they owned both sides they
just wanted to see which one was the
easiest to control people with
um the the entire system's fake it's
fake and it's rigged
Jeff yards lets people run this not you
I went to Old yeah I don't run [ __ ]
right we don't run [ __ ] we're just
dealing with them I'm you know yeah no
matter who you vote for it's a candidate
they approved for and it's in their
pocket yeah Jeff yard said I went to a
Colonial Village on a school trip where
they revealed people used old corn cobs
as toilet paper yeah that's true as
before toilet paper whole new meaning to
cornhole I mean it's better than a corn
hole in them not wiping your butt at all
but
why are corn cob specific because they
had them laying around I guess they had
them laying around they weren't good for
anything else better than a pine cone
yeah
okay cheer your booty hole up well now
see what we were saying before about the
Romans and like the sponge on the stick
yeah it's not so much the sponge on the
stick that I'm uh that I'm mad at it's
the fact that you're using the same
sponge on the stick for every
[ __ ] yeah if you had a clean one
every time that would actually be pretty
good and evidently they would swash it
off into the water and dude squeeze it
Dash it down in the water to clean it
so somebody's squeezing it so much so
much disease yeah just thinking about it
gives me a disease
I probably have some diseases right now
just thinking about that [ __ ]
they're in I don't even like look I
don't even like if I'm
here's the thing if I'm eating
and I have to pick up a piece of food
with my hand like a piece of chicken or
something I don't even like the feel of
like food on my fingers for like a
minute
I'm hardened to it much less like
squeezing from you know the sponge well
I always feel like oh my God I gotta
wash my hands I gotta wash my hands yeah
I'm like that and here's the thing their
cleaning solution was [ __ ] uh a piss
the mo the uh they would take piss which
is probably the only thing they would
turn and save them yeah
and sell that as a cleaning solution
evidently there was she was real
lucrative if you owned a latrine or a
public bathroom you could get your hands
on all that piss yeah and they would
yeah they would put it through a process
and turn into a cleaning solution you
know nothing was wasted which is not
crazy I mean yeah that's not good they
separated us somehow they had some
process to do it but
but here's the thing not bagging on the
ancient Romans at that time they were
[ __ ] Cutting Edge well like if they
were cleaner than all the others cleaner
than everybody else and they were a
[ __ ] very sophisticated Society if
you read some of their best political uh
writings uh uh you know [ __ ]
political commentary
um you'll see that it's like it was
written by somebody today you know I
mean they were
they're educated people [ __ ] had it
together yeah they weren't dumb they
even [ __ ] would say things like yeah
well we must respect the gods because
that holds Society together but we as
educated people know that these gods
were based on something that is probably
long gone probably rulers from the past
or they're based on Concepts uh and
they're not really based on anything
historical at all
which that's a very sophisticated
thinking there you know what I mean that
our religions are not based on anything
other than just well yeah I told you I
[ __ ] I have a book called
um free thinkers by Susan Jacoby and she
it was like pretty much like atheism
throughout the evening yeah and yeah
you'd be surprised like how far that uh
those lineup goes away a thousands of
waves like way back then they knew like
educated people knew that that it was
[ __ ] yeah well no they didn't think
it was [ __ ] well that's you know
what I mean they knew that it wasn't
literally it wasn't literal true it was
a way of teaching values and holding
societies together because uneducated
people needed to believe in things and
this is how you you created Unity inside
of a diverse population that's basically
what basically what they're talking
about
is that you need something to hold
people together belief a belief system
without it they all turn on one another
talking about the butt sponges Ben says
that's untrue the sponge on the stick
got replaced every few months
it helped people build their resistance
to disease maybe it probably did up to a
point it's just uh but after a point
just nasty after that point like um the
shit's gonna overwhelm your immune
system so that's why people didn't live
that long back then I think well uh I
know I think uh the the rich people in
general well rich people in general live
a long time in the 70s they lived yeah
they live pretty good and the thing
about it too I think it's a little bit
of a myth that people didn't live as
long I mean poor people always died
young they still died young but um I
think it's a myth that the um that
people didn't live quite as long because
the uh averages were skewed because a
lot of people died in childbirth in like
childhood they're factoring in infant
mortality in the morning right and and
more so that brings the average weight
average weight and the average in Rome I
think was 30. that life expectancy was
average was 30. but what it was is the
infant mortality was so high that the
[ __ ] brought the average down well
and [ __ ] that was up until the Victorian
area right because I mean even you know
well in very prominent families in the
Victorian era like it was very very
common for them to have like eight kids
and then like only like six of them you
know six of them died and like two of
them lived to adulthood or some [ __ ]
like that and that was very very common
even among families that were you know
wealthy for the time so yeah that's it
brings the average down the main
difference between today and Rome
well you know okay
today there would be a big difference
but let's just say
the differences between
Rome and the late 1800s was slight
actually there wasn't a big difference
the beginning of the Industrial
Revolution actually was already
happening in Rome they had steam engines
they just didn't apply them because they
had slave labor they didn't need labor
saving devices there was only a couple
things that they could have built that
would have helped them but they'd
they guess they couldn't get investors
they never really could think about it
two things that would have saved them
was the steam locomotive that would have
really helped them out
because you would you could have gotten
a Roman legion to the far
far regions of the [ __ ] Empire and
[ __ ] stop Barbarian attacks which
would have increased [ __ ]
um uh uh uh what do you call it
investment in in in in in in the outer
provinces which would caused it to grow
so they really needed a steam locomotive
and then the other thing that would have
helped him really really well would have
been the telegraph
but they didn't have a concept of
electricity but they probably could have
figured that out
it wasn't far off right but the steam
locomotive they had the technology they
knew all about it but
they never applied it to Locomotion
I never thought of it
but they had the steam engines
they were using them they were using to
do things like open and close doors
to Temples using [ __ ] water clocks so
the temple doors would open and close at
the set time
um which is cool but yeah but it's just
funny that they couldn't take that like
extra step and think like oh this has
like a lot more applications well they
may have been using steam engine to do
things like [ __ ] crushed grain to
make flour that's another thing that
could which but you know that's another
good thing where you can use it for sure
but all you had to do is put that on
Wheels they had Wheels if you put that
on Wheels you could run something with
it and if you put those Wheels inside of
tracks you'd not have a locomotive
motive and uh that would have helped him
but
I never applied it they were the their
thinking wasn't like ours I guess into a
certain way
they were just so tied up in slave labor
the rich people all had these huge
tracks of land and they were growing
food
and uh using German slaves
and it just depressed the economy and it
depressed the growth of Technology well
yeah that's what I mean when when you
don't have
um when it's not necessary like to make
these big like leaps in you know
progress then they don't you know they
get comfortable like you said they had
people to do all that stuff yeah and
that didn't look like it was going
anywhere so they didn't really feel the
need to like innovate into any area
Innovation and Technology always has is
always centered around labor saving okay
yeah it's always a little bit out of
necessity yes I kind of feel like yeah
yeah we're like we need to eliminate
this [ __ ] he's too expensive so
we need to come up with this techno and
slaves were almost damn near free you
know that's what I mean so for a long
time that kind of like and that's kind
of the shitty thing is that that might
have suppressed yeah uh technology like
progress in technology for a really long
time because nobody felt the need to
like hey we got people to do that and
they don't cost anything I had had just
[ __ ] up but it's probably true Rome
did weird things like an emperor would
come in and he'd free all the slaves and
all those slaves would become citizens
they did resets all the time
but they never abolished it
so so the last thing so they never
really got rid of the problem that was
[ __ ] oppressing you know or
suppressing the technological growth and
an emperor come and abolished slavery
you would have had an industrial
revolution
it would have happened because you know
you you can't have slaves so now you
have to you need labor savings figure
something out to figure something out
you need to make machines that do that
work
and that would have started an
industrial revolution they already had
much earlier much earlier what he would
have been on a damn Moon
probably like a 480. we didn't mean
living on the Moon by now yeah just like
the sci-fi movie said well think about
it now by the same timeline we had been
on the moon and [ __ ] uh yeah
200 A.D that's what I mean that's not
weird no
because the [ __ ] that they figured out
in the before the industrial 200 years I
mean that well and the knowledge was
always there it's just they didn't
figure it out for whatever reason yeah
you know what I mean it's the science is
always the same
they just needed somebody to like figure
it out yeah and nobody did because they
didn't really need to
Oracle says uh hi Oracle Oracle just
showed up you have to wonder what
resources we have now that future people
will shake their heads at our blindness
about I kind of wonder about that too
like I kind of well the first thing is
nuclear you can do a lot with nuclear
that we're not doing because they're
scared of it which is stupid because you
can make reactors [ __ ] really [ __ ]
well nowadays if you start from scratch
there's a lot of older reactors out
there but you can make badass reactors
right now
and um
there was a bunch of treaties about
making nuclear power against making
nuclear-powered aircraft
we made a few but it was real old old
technology like 50s technology
I would imagine there's probably some
secret nuclear aircraft out there
but uh because there's different ways
you can do it
so nuclear alone is not being nuclear is
not being tapped properly
that's the first thing
um a lot of biotechs out there a lot of
it
that probably like
rewriting the [ __ ] DNA
in your system to make yourself grow
younger
that's another thing
they might know about that maybe now you
think that the the super wealthy would
be using if they had it because they'd
be able to buy it
so maybe not but
if they had that they wouldn't let that
out because it's in their vested
interest to have a lot of us die because
we're kind of obsolete and they want the
population to drop
so they can inherit the Garden of Eden
basically
you don't need all these obsolete Farm
Workers and Factory workers just walking
around forever let they want us to age
out a lot of us
so immortality is probably possible but
they would keep that [ __ ] time they
would keep that [ __ ] other wraps
Oracle says I'll go you on better Tom
what if nuclear waste is an untapped
resource what a future Generations yeah
wonder why we threw that away yeah oh
yeah that's probably true well you got
depleted uranium you can use it as a you
could use it as [ __ ] a very dense
[ __ ] armor-piercing weapon there's
all kinds of stuff but there's all gonna
be all kinds of weird [ __ ] we can do
things see I think that's maybe where uh
we should be aiming some [ __ ] is like
how to repurpose
waste like stuff that's thrown away
whether it's nuclear waste or whether
it's garbage or weather whatever I kind
of feel like that's probably a good yeah
what's funny is that the nuclear stuff
and the nuclear waste is [ __ ] way
blowing out of proportion because the
the Earth itself is jam-packed full of
[ __ ] uranium
and [ __ ] nuclear products deep down
into the Earth it's just everywhere
those that shit's actually very common
you just have to learn how to dispose of
it properly
you're going to drop it down something
real deep and make sure it doesn't come
back out there but it's down there
anyway because then you get the Toxic
Avenger and nobody gets Toxic Event yeah
although no Toxic Avenger was like a
superhero but that [ __ ] that
um you know mining uranium is very
dangerous it's [ __ ] you know
radioactive as [ __ ] and that stuff's all
down there [ __ ] in the crust of the
Earth
um
space travel is getting
cheaper and safer eventually you can
just take that [ __ ] out into space and
just fling it off it won't make any
goddamn difference
[Laughter]
dirty eating outer space man you don't
know what's out there in outer space
outer space is a [ __ ] dangerous super
highly radioactive [ __ ] environment
that nuclear waste is nothing compared
to what's out there you're cleaning it
up when you throw that [ __ ] out there
compared to some of the high radiation
well I mean in spaces big too it's big
yeah I mean so
Linux where he said really enjoying this
it's like a vintage 13 o'clock
discussion is it we didn't mean for it
to be but yeah I'm sorry
[Laughter]
but that's what happens well we're the
same [ __ ] that we're always
like talking about the same stuff so you
know what I mean
uh jeffreyard said it seems like
technology isn't pursued unless there's
a mass monetary commercial Bingo yeah
Bingo exactly which is kind of a shame
but yeah not really that's what are you
gonna do that's the most reliable way uh
is that it's so many profits from it so
this is what we're gonna do and that's
the way it's always been
that goes back to sailing ships and just
and [ __ ] exploring the Earth and
trying to map the planet that was all
because of money you know
they were trying to find Passage to
India that kind of [ __ ]
Oracle said all we need now is to talk
about Pookie and Beijing and cooking
no why not okay
you know what's funny I went down to do
the laundry the other day
and Beijing was in the litter box which
is in the laundry room
and I even like I went around with the
basket and then I saw her and then I was
like oh I'm sorry yeah
did she know you gave her privacy I
guess yeah
those are like oh I'm sorry sweetie then
I just like I just hit in the back until
she came out and then she like kind of
looked up at me I'm like it's cool I
didn't want to like watch it
it's [ __ ] weird Oracle said did I
miss that um we did talk about Pokey
earlier because she was I think she was
playing with the toys she was playing
with the toys in the back like we kind
of moved my chair so you could see her
but I think she
she
ate some of the food over there and she
was like [ __ ] this I'm bored and she
like went away I don't know where she
went to she maybe went downstairs to
like beat up on uh Beijing maybe the
good thing about it is that I had that
chicken already made down there
yeah so you so you don't have to like
worry about it you're already thinking
about food yeah I'm getting hungry yeah
[Laughter]
he's already getting hungry yeah I'm
getting hungry you are starting to look
like Anton LaVey a little bit yeah
you're gonna start doing like this is
starting to get thinner too because that
[ __ ] tree yeah that trend is eating a
lot of fat out of me I wasn't sure that
I would like the beard but I kind of I
kind of like it yeah I kind of like it a
lot of people are saying it looks good
on me if I can uh Connor Watson says
yeah that fits you man
yeah yeah it makes you look more evil so
that so that like kind of fits in with
your personality all the biker all the
biker [ __ ] bartender girls [ __ ]
liked it they're like oh yeah yeah
that's it that's a facial hair facial
hair yeah that's what you that's it
[Laughter]
yeah you went down to the biker bar
yesterday didn't you was it yesterday
yeah
no day before from this day before yeah
maybe it was just I think it was
yesterday yeah it was yesterday because
um we didn't live stream yesterday yeah
and you said oh well I can go out for a
ride and be gone and I said yeah you
don't have to be back at a certain time
yeah nighttime bartender came in so he
was gone until like [ __ ] I don't know
I'd already watched like most of the
shutter show and I was like already like
had a drink and everything before he got
back nighttime bartender came in and
they're kind of and her and her husband
came in there and they're like in their
late 20s and um they're kind of like a
kind of like a golf couple kinda and
kind of like a Tony and elated type
situation a little bit younger and I
showed them our pictures and [ __ ] and
they're like oh yeah and I showed them
where mannequins was and [ __ ] I sent
him invites to go to mannequins and
everything so they want to go to the
club we'll have to take him to the
Halloween party the thing is that she
works on Fridays and Saturdays that's
what I figured nice she's the boss she
has to get she has to get those those
times off and she's like one of their
she's like one of their hot new
bartender top bartender girls you know
what I'm talking about and he the
husband's got to show up to keep an eye
on her you know what I mean that was
that was funny about it but you know I
understand
it's kind of a dangerous place you know
yeah I don't know if I'd really want to
uh bartend in a place like that
you know you have to be a certain type
of girl to [ __ ] if I can Amy [ __ ]
has a great time there because she's a
micro she's a biker chick yeah
like that culture then sure yeah if
you're not I wouldn't but she knows all
the biker gangs and [ __ ] you know I mean
you're not nobody's gonna [ __ ] with her
you're gonna have [ __ ] two or three
gags coming out yeah it's got to be
somebody like that right yeah gotta be
somebody like that
I wouldn't put like we'll have the
warlocks coming after you and the
[ __ ] Banditos and [ __ ]
you did what you know so you know so
some of the some of those girls are
heavily protected
which like I said you'd have to be
they're popular
Oracle says our cats went to the vet
Wednesday they both have kidney disease
now yeah they're winding down their
brothers and 16 years old oh
that makes me sad don't make me think
about it
I mean Pookie's only five but still
Beijing is how old now 12. yeah about
that 12 or 13. oracle's talking about me
being the merciless yeah
what about that that would be a good
costume too that's an expensive costume
it is yeah maybe next year and the thing
is is that the red one is the most
recognizable one but his coolest one was
the black and gold
uniform that Ming wore while he was
watching [ __ ] his daughter princess
Aura would being tortured by the boar
worms
he showed up in the black [ __ ] outfit
remember that one that was his like
instant that was his outfit yeah his
black outfit he's eating the [ __ ]
little [ __ ] hors d'oeuvres and [ __ ]
while she's getting tortured
he's like yeah I'm into this yeah it's
my fetish yeah yeah that tripped me out
as a kid I was like this is [ __ ]
this is the father and daughter and like
it's insinuating that they're getting it
on
was it isn't that isn't that that's what
I picked up I mean yeah or did you pick
up that Vibe too but like I said I guess
that was she's just all over him and
[ __ ] oh well like I said I guess that
was kind of the way that they were going
with that because they were like aliens
so they were like degenerate yeah every
[ __ ] every Mingo or [ __ ] whatever
you know I think they called a Mingos
yeah every one of them was [ __ ]
sexually perverted they were in [ __ ]
BDSM and [ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ]
well see I kind of feel like maybe that
was so much better than Star Wars I was
like well because in some ways if it's
sci-fi yeah like if you make them aliens
then you can get away with a lot of
salacious [ __ ] that you wouldn't be able
to get away with if they were humans
because you're like what they're not
even from this planet that's just like
what they do there yeah what are you
gonna do you know what I mean so you can
like make you can excuse it like in that
way I get it although uh
reading I was reading an analysis of
[ __ ] Flash Gordon from the 20s the
30s when it came out
Domingos and making the merciless and
all that actually
were metaphors
or uh allegories
for Europeans what it is is Americans
showing up in Europe
trying to show that they're good-hearted
people and trying to get all these
degenerate Europeans to stop fighting
one another
that's what it was yeah I could see that
that's what they were actually talking
about that's it yeah back in the 20s and
30s all these degenerate Europe
degenerate Europeans without any morals
with their stinky cigarettes and their
two-hour lunches yeah and just [ __ ]
everything that moves
and then [ __ ] flash shows up and he's
actually a polo player in the original
thing and he's looking you know hey my
name is [ __ ] you know my name is
Flash and they're all [ __ ] I'm the
most american-american that ever
Americans yeah yeah
I have good morals
it's so funny and like simplistic like
what do you think about it but like you
yeah it's pretty obvious yeah these
Empires using divide and conquer tactics
you need to gang up and get rid of these
people so we can have a democracy that's
what that's basically what they're
talking about
we'll all get along in a republic
Oracle says uh Jenny I have another book
recommendation for you the bone houses
by Emily Lloyd Jones spooky medieval
Welsh novel about a family of Undertaker
see I'm already my interest is already
peaked I wrote it down by the way so I
actually will uh get around to reading
that so thank you for the recommendation
Mark says zero trash yeah that's what
they're talking about Euro tray well
yeah did you write those degenerates
they're just jealous because the
Europeans were having more fun than them
uh Mark says there was a lot of wild
[ __ ] going on in the United States too
well I know that but Americans have
probably not nowadays but for a long
time Americans had a reputation uh among
Europeans for being very puritanical and
like you're they probably were
comparison that's what I mean had no
patience for that kind of stuff yeah
they thought they were like super
uptight
uh Mark said my neighbors growing up had
a cat that was possibly near 20 years
old and Oracle said I've had a cat that
made it to 20. yeah I've seen some cats
like that lived into their 20s it's not
it you know it doesn't happen that often
but it does happen we had some friends
that had a cat that was 22 23. when she
died I think something like that
but
like I said I know Pookie's only five
but that's like something that I think
about a lot it's like man she needs to
like live a really long time but she
just she doesn't yeah what I'm busy
she's like but Brushy yeah
she's over there by the
I was like I have a bathroom and then
there's like a little dressing area
there that has like a sink and like a
closet and stuff and that's where I keep
pookies um bro it used to be my
hairbrush but she kind of like took it
so when she wants brush she goes over
there and like looks at me and yells and
then jumps up on the sink and is like
hey come brush me so that's what she
just did Tom got up and she was like
and she went over there and was like
hey Brushy and then yeah
I don't know man I told her earlier I
was like man she loves that brush more
than
anyone has ever loved anything I I don't
understand it
she will just lay there for ages and
just let me brush it with it's just like
a regular [ __ ] it's a human hairbrush
I have gloves too like I have those
little gloves that have like the you
know that you pet the cat and it's like
I've got a brush on it I got those two
and she kind of likes those but
her favorite thing is just this cheap
[ __ ] five dollar hair brush that I've
had like forever and you know I had to
buy a new hairbrush because now that
one's all full of her hair but you know
what I mean
uh let's see
Camp guy said I have a 15 year old cat
but we live out in the woods away from
traffic yeah Beijing is I think she's 12
or 13 I think she goes outside but
Pookie doesn't go outside anymore she
doesn't like to go outside um since we
moved to the new house which is fine
with me
um she jumps up on the window and looks
outside but she doesn't want to go
outside anymore and that's fine
she used to go outside at the old house
and I used to worry about her all the
time so I'm glad that she's scared of it
I don't know why I think it's because
maybe our neighbor has dogs and she's
scared of dogs so she doesn't like to go
outside because she thinks oh my God
dogs you know what I mean so she'll like
sit up on the windowsill and look
outside but she doesn't go out Beijing
will go out but she usually just sits on
the back porch
and that's what
what
what's the matter
what's the matter what are you talking
about
what are you talking about
come up here what are you talking about
she comes in here
like yelling and [ __ ] like that I don't
know what she's yelling about
yeah Oracle said our guys are strictly
indoor cats we have Hawks in the area
yeah I'm like really really worried
about it I didn't really like it like I
said I didn't like it when she went
outside at the old house but she was
just like crying cry and cry she wanted
to go outside and she mostly stayed in
the backyard but sometimes she would go
like way down to the pond which was like
two or three houses down sometimes she
would like um kind of Wiggle under the
fence and go into the it wasn't the road
it was like that was far but she would
go like into there was like a little um
like a walking path back there and
sometimes she would go and hide in the
bushes back then we'd have to go like
dig her out but I don't know since we
moved to the new house she she
absolutely does not want to go outside
anymore
and I think that happened
when we were still at our old house I
went to
um St Augustine for a few days
on vacation
and Tom stayed home with Pokey
and while I was gone pookie was outside
and a new neighbor moved in at our old
house and the new neighbor had a dog and
the dog was like really friendly and the
dog was like oh hey look a little kitty
and like came over to meet her and
Pookie freaked out she freaked out so
bad that she um had a little bit of a
panic attack and started trying to get
into the house
how many houses down was the house that
pookie was trying to get into and like
two houses down yeah yeah she went to
the front door and was like let me in
let me in oh my God like the dog is like
and Tom had to go two houses down to be
like this is my cat sorry like she
thinks this is her house because she
panicked and she like her little foot
got messed it was like it was fine she's
fine yeah come on but let me give her a
little bit of brush yeah he's gonna
brush her because she keeps yelling she
keeps yelling she's been good but um so
since that time like she wounded her
foot a little bit like I think her
little
um claw like a back claw in her back
foot like got wounded while she was
running and like it didn't break or
nothing like that but she it's fine but
it it hurt for a little while but after
that she lost all her enthusiasm about
going outside and she now is terrified
of dogs so I think because the neighbors
here have dogs
and they're outside sometimes like in
the fence like right next like she
doesn't want to go outside because she
just like hears them and she's like [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
she makes me a lot happier like Beijing
um she's been going outside for years
and years and she usually like just sits
on the back porch and it's fine but
pookie I always worried about her like
when we were at the old house and she
insisted on going outside I didn't like
it I didn't like it out here the the
danger isn't those dogs though no I'm
not I'm not worried about the dogs just
any dogs really statistically the dogs
are not statistically the problems are
eagles
Eagle yeah eagles and owls
and they'll grab it and getting hit by a
car I'm worried about that too uh
statistically Eagle yeah
well that's what Oracle was saying he
was more worried about hawks yeah
working in those barns where there's
always Barn cats you got to replace a
barn Cat every four or five years Eagles
get them
and then there was a time where we had
to replace
had to replace a cat once a year I think
that went on for like two years ago and
that was here just up the road at that
one that I was working at back in 2008.
that's what I'm saying I'm not every
year had to replace the barn cats I'm
not risking it because you know you got
to have a barn cat yeah keep [ __ ] out of
the barn
and here they were [ __ ] keeping
spiders out
that bar was infested with spiders the
size they were that big
big old [ __ ] hunting spiders white
spiders my grandpa's house used to have
some spiders yeah I'd come in to start
[ __ ] feeding up the horses and put
them out
give them their medicine in the morning
there's about [ __ ] 20 of them 20
horses
and in the center of the aisle of the
[ __ ] Barn if you walk down that
center aisle you probably won
two
three
and that kind of killed four of those
spiders at night
because they were all up in the ceiling
yeah and they come down she'd get up all
night long
there's lots of them in there
see that's the funny thing about Pookie
too is that if a if a spider or a roach
or something gets in the house Pookie
will absolutely warn you about it yeah
she's like monster monster you guys that
she'll like [ __ ] jump around like I
have she doesn't want to touch it
because she's grossed out but she'll
like
I'd be falling asleep in the damn man
cave and had her run up I'm just little
feet and I'm going what the [ __ ]
I was sleeping on a damn [ __ ] uh mat
one time
I had a little cabin Matt I was sleeping
on in a sleeping bag
listening to my headphones is that way
Jenny can go to sleep without me waking
her up because I'll [ __ ] start
yelling and [ __ ] talking in my
sleeping [ __ ] sometimes and uh his
little feet are [ __ ] hitting me and
[ __ ] and I'm looking and she struck him
stepping on me with with three feet and
then a fourth the [ __ ] hand she's
boom boom smacks
she's got one of the palmetto bug
and she's trying to stun the palmetto
bug it's coming for you it's coming for
you today it was I guess
she was trying
she's very protective yeah she's coming
for you so I'm like what what the [ __ ] I
could get up and [ __ ] grab the damn
knife and [ __ ] killed it
and then had to scoop it up with them
toilet paper doing that [ __ ] naked
swinging
trying to fight the damn palmetto bugs
which is what happens that's what
Florida is in fact one time in that old
house These are nice [ __ ] houses it's
just that you got all this glass and
sliding glass doors and [ __ ]
and this is Florida
is just like just struggling with bugs
and alligators and lizards and
alligators Bears yeah and this is
everything and this is happening in
upper middle class higher class
um
suburbs this is not even the country I
mean you can't keep that [ __ ] out yeah
it lives with you the ends the outside
will come inside at some point we were
in this beautiful suburb [ __ ]
price [ __ ] 500 pound bear
its shoulder will just come up to about
this tall see that there's all kinds of
stuff I'm in there working on a bike and
they're [ __ ] bear look around the
corner at me and what's up what you
doing so what's up man I always greet
the bear because they'll run
they'll run from you if you greet them
you don't want to run from them they
might chase you okay because you're
acting like you're pregnant what's up
bear what you doing come on in come on
in hey what are you doing they're like
oh then they start running
wait I can't eat that dude yeah
[Laughter]
but um
I was laying up in the bed next to her
and [ __ ] woke up like that and
[ __ ] one of them [ __ ] palmetto
bugs is running across my chest
yeah yeah
it happens sometimes yes and you got to
be careful
I would [ __ ] um
got in a habit of [ __ ] leaving like a
soda yeah with ice on the [ __ ]
nightstand
wake up and [ __ ] drink that [ __ ]
one morning I woke up [ __ ] went to go
get a drink looked down there's a dead
palmetto bug in it that's just that's it
no more [ __ ] soda on the side of the
bed because I was drinking that [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the middle of the night yep
and I never got hit but
look you know because they'll go down
there to get a drink and fall in yeah
and who knows how many times it went in
there and got a drink and successfully
and got out and you didn't I didn't even
know that's what I'm saying right that's
why I don't leave drinks on the side
like I'll take a drink in there with me
at night like usually ice water yeah so
I can drink it like while I'm watching a
movie or whatever but I just like I I
drink it all and I just leave it yeah I
don't I don't leave anything in there
and these aren't German cockroaches
yeah they're big they're big man these
are [ __ ] Palmetto but like that big
they live in these palmetto trees and
then they come into a house they can
smell they got a real good sense of
smell big long antennas
and they can smell if you got food out
and a house is no defense they'll come
right underneath they can squeeze right
in between sliding glass doors where
they I mean if you can get a piece of
paper yeah under a door then they can
come in under a door they'll come right
into your front door
you know even if you have weather
stripping they'll just push that outside
yeah whatever no big deal okay
I'm a roach I'll go where I want it
right
so you'll see most Florida houses
especially in the kitchen
where you keep uh food pantries
and where your pots and pans are inside
those Cupboards in the corners you'll
see little roach traps poisons not traps
poison
that's a good sign that's not a bad sign
it's a good sign
it's a bad sign if you don't have that
that means you're probably going to get
an infestation it's a good sign if you
do have that because you're stopping in
an infestation from ever happening
because they constantly come in
I bet you every week there's probably
two or three of them that come in and
they find that poison first because
you're leaving it out they eat that and
they die there's never an infestation if
you do that
I mean Florida skill the new house isn't
too bad because you don't get too many
bugs coming to the second floor like
every now and then you find some [ __ ]
like downstairs yeah but yeah but it's
not like the old place which was all one
floor I'll find every now and then
you'll find them um in pieces out here
in the hallway well Beijing Beijing
likes to tear them up tear them up
Pookie is grossed out by them which I
don't you know I don't blame her because
I am too but maximum starts crying
she'll smack him and like start yelling
like come like please come kill it look
look like she tries to like warn us
about it yeah but Beijing won't she'll
just like she'll just kill it and eat
most of it and then like leave a leg or
like a head or something yeah like
Beijing will do she's she doesn't give a
[ __ ] she'll let you know I killed one
yeah yeah and then like you'll get up
the next morning and she kind of like
looks over there and just like there's a
room like it's part of it she ate the
other
[Laughter]
she thinks they're disgusting yeah but
she'll she'll warn you about them though
which like I said that's that's kind of
her job I kind of feel like she feels
like her job is guarding mommy and daddy
from from Palmetto books from Palm
palmetto bugs and also from Beijing
coming upstairs yeah her big thing like
I'll get up in the middle of the night
to go to the bathroom yeah that's
[ __ ] funny well Beijing will come up
here and then like she'll she always
feels like she's sneaking yeah you know
what I mean like I'll see her like every
now and then I'll be in the office and
I'll look around the corner and I'll see
Beijing yeah it should be like like
she's not supposed to be here and I'm
like I'm like hey pretty girl and she's
just kind of like uh uh am I in the
wrong place and then Pookie like hears
me and she's like oh that [ __ ] is up
here and then starts because Pookie kind
of feels like this is her Michael's
asking does AC in Florida keep your
house at least down to 75-77
um you can get it down to [ __ ] 70.
but it'll cost you
this house is nowhere near as expensive
as I thought this house is actually
cheaper to cool than our one-story house
that we had I think because it has less
glass
yeah that's probably and we have two
Central units well that's probably also
a big so they're not working very hard
so not running all the time
um
in this house I think we set it at West
74.
73 yeah 70 I think it's at seven three
thousand I think it's 73. and it's 73
and this house feels nice and cool
most in some of the most of the rooms
for me
um
73 would have felt really hot in the
other house because it had so much glass
um I mean it was a pretty house it was
just a pretty modern
house like you'd see when you're looking
at [ __ ]
Florida porn you know [ __ ] porn when
you see porn today most of that shit's
in Florida that's his that's his yeah
that's right you guys know know what it
looks like you see it all the time okay
[ __ ] when
Angela White's out there in the [ __ ]
backyard with the [ __ ] beautiful
backyard in the [ __ ] pool and [ __ ]
and then they go in the house and [ __ ]
that's those are Florida houses newer
ones
yeah
they have
it was real con it was uh back like 10
15 years ago it was very much in style
to build those houses with lots and lots
of glass
they gave him kind of a tropical
appearance because like oh they're
pretty it's inside and outside at the
same time but yeah it also makes it like
much harder to cool yeah you gotta that
was that was during the time when energy
was a lot cheaper I think to cool that
now as if that [ __ ] went up
the newer ones have less glass in them
and more uh cinder blocks because a lot
of it's cinder block it has to be
because of the hurricanes
well yeah this house is a lot cooler
this house is cinder block on the ground
floor and on the second floor which you
don't see a lot usually the ground even
if the ground floor is cinder block a
lot of times the second floor will just
be wood but this one is cinder block all
the way up and it also has a front door
that opens inward inward like a damn
trailer which is unusual but that's what
it's a new that's what the new hurricane
standards like to keep like prevent the
door from blowing in or blowing out or
whatever going out no hey keep it from
blowing in it opens out yeah like a
[ __ ] trailer instead of right right
instead of it tacky if you ask me but
but that's how well no that's how they
do it it's like a safety thing and the
thing about it is that
um this house
this office where we're uh you know live
streaming from is usually cold it's
usually like so cold in here that I have
to wear a jacket but the bedroom
is usually kind of warm and I think it's
because it didn't have an overhead fan
it yeah it doesn't have a ceiling fan
which is unusual because most fans uh in
modern houses in FLorida slope ceiling
and there's no ceiling fan installed in
it
got a solution we got one of those
little bar little yeah I just got like a
tall like column fan you just put it on
and it's small enough to go on the
nightstand yeah and it blows right
across that it hits it goes yeah and it
was only 40 bucks and it looks nice yeah
I got a 40 Buck fan and it was even like
one of the safer ones that it's like
because I was worried about it's like
well I don't want a pokey going in there
like sticking her [ __ ] paw into the
[ __ ] because you know how she does about
anything that's new she's like oh what's
this thing but the one I got was like
you know touted as like being safe for
pets and babies and stuff like that so
yeah it worked out good it worked out
good it's it's very very powerful like I
said for only forty dollars and like I
said it's just doesn't make any noise it
sits on the nightstand it's it's pretty
quiet yeah too it's probably about
it's about three feet three feet tall
but it's only about that the footprint's
only that big on it yeah it's got like a
base about that big and then it's just
kind of like a column looks like a big
old air freshener if you ask me it does
and it kind of minutes and it oscillates
like that yeah too I mean if you want it
to you can just have it be still but we
have an oscillating because like I said
I dig around is that glass yeah I can't
really sleep if it's hot and I had been
having trouble sleeping in that room
because I'm like it's kind of Stuffy in
here yeah and so I'd always been like
kicking the covers off and I was like
waking up all the time it's been better
since I got that fan yeah thanks Sly
started saying I'm looking good
that's my new trend stack I got a weak
left
then I'm going on a win straw [ __ ]
site
gotta get these last [ __ ] pounds off
then once I get where I want I'm just
going to maintain it after that it'll be
easy it's always the losing part the
losing and gaining that's the hard part
once you get once you get to where you
want to go it's easy to maintain
but it's you know it's it's a lifestyle
Jeffery Arts had a palmetto bug crawled
into my apartment once I trapped it in a
coffee can and tried to carry it outside
it escaped and crawled up my arm yeah
flung it off so hard outside that it
exploded on impact do you know what I
had happened one time like and this was
a long time ago this was like my at my
grandmother's old house in Daytona
I went in there and I was getting a
shirt out of my closet that had a pocket
in it and I put the shirt on and a
[ __ ] palmetto bug crawled out the
pocket
like while I was oh my God I had a
[ __ ] heart attack
like a I'm a lot better about it
nowadays for a long time I just could
not even deal with them
because you have to think too that it's
like I grew up here like I was born in
Daytona Beach Florida I've lived in
Daytona most of my life
and the houses I grew up in you know
they weren't infested but you got
roaches like on a pretty regular thing
and I was never able to get used to them
so I was always it'd be like a thing
where you'd wake up in the middle of the
night and you'd hear
need snuck in and you'd hear that like
you could they're so big that you can
hear their [ __ ] legs as they walk
across your wall and then I'd wake up
and be like [ __ ] no and like sometimes
like one night I and I still remember
this clearly I woke up one night and I
heard that and I was like [ __ ]
I was like do I really want to turn the
light on and see where this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is and then all of a sudden I felt
Boop Atlanta oh wait it landed right in
between my tits damn oh my God I flipped
out I was like blood I like jumped out
of bed and I was like I I slept on the
couch that night no thank you no thank
you ah so gross
[ __ ] gross
yeah it's a constant battle they're
trying to get in yeah although look
it's not as bad as it was when I was a
kid
I remember going to Mississippi to visit
my dad
in the summertime
and the [ __ ] bugs were [ __ ] oh 100
times what they are now
every [ __ ] parking every light over a
parking lot was a swarm of [ __ ] bugs
at night going around yeah I remember
the bug lights outside my grandma bug
lights outside the dam those bug zappers
outside the back of every house just
constantly going
snapping and killing all those [ __ ]
bugs
cicadas giant [ __ ] cicadas
um
then you'd have also in the summer these
huge black grasshoppers called them
locusts they'd be black with yellow
stripes on them those things were
everywhere
um
yeah it was just uh in the 70s it was
[ __ ] mind-boggling it's nowhere near
as bad as it was
so
we cry about it complain about a [ __ ]
occasional
palmetto bug but it was nothing what it
was in the 70s the 70s it was just like
like the pontanal which is like
in Brazil you know and [ __ ] Amazon
basin it's like that
[ __ ] and we got places that look like
that not far from here look like a dam
swamp you know
[ __ ] water and [ __ ] trees and [ __ ]
uh
what it is like degobook
you can put all the pretty houses and
golf [ __ ] quartz is a huge golf court
here you know Golf Course here at Black
Bear Reserve
we saw a bear the other day on the back
porch too
Big Bear
probably about
I don't know 350 pound bear
bigger than a man
walking across the back porch
hanging out looking for stuff to eat but
uh it's nowhere yeah it was out on the
back
but uh now in town there's nothing
compared to what it was in the 70s when
it came to the bugs how bad it was back
then
well that's mostly a number well I don't
know about 70s but I'm mostly
remembering like 80s yeah even the 80s
it was bad yeah it was [ __ ] there was
a lot more of them I don't know why I
think maybe because it wasn't as
it wasn't as densely populated
and so the bugs are getting killed at a
higher rate and maybe might have
something to do with pesticides
killed them off
but it used to be like the Amazon basin
here
yeah lots of them yeah I remember that
every summer college right yeah I mean
we dreaded summer for lots of reasons
yeah mostly because of bugs summer but
you know but because of bugs remember
how big those [ __ ] huge black locusts
with the [ __ ] yellow stripes in them
they'd attack you yeah with their wings
threaten you and [ __ ] from the ground
like [ __ ] you you try to crush them
and they would crack and pop it was like
stepping on a [ __ ]
oh it was like stepping on a crawdad
was like stepping on a crawdad
I stepped on one by accident sometime
and I still remember that [ __ ]
like I was taking a walk and I guess I
was like talking or something that I
didn't realize and then the person I was
with was like you realize he just
stepped on one of those big yeah and I
was like what I was like oh my God I was
so gross and they had cicadas that were
bigger than mice they were like that big
they were that big and like that big
around huge
big wings on them and they had fur
that's the only bug I've ever seen had
fur they'd be kind of like a light green
on the top and they'd be Tan on the
bottom or [ __ ] white on the bottom
white fur on a damn bug
remember that yeah it was like a fine
fur creepy with those [ __ ] eyes
sticking off either side and [ __ ]
Wings on it
[Laughter]
they'd be like don't kill it that's a 12
year Locust
they called a 12 year Locust to be
honest
I'm not bothered Yeah by any bugs other
than cockroaches I'm not bothered by
spiders I'm not bothered by bees I'm not
really even bothered by wasps I don't
want them like [ __ ] making a nest in
my because uh wasps did make a nest in
my um uh you know in my car like where
you open the thing to put the gas in
there was a little wasp nest in there
which I was very surprised to find like
when I went in there to like uh force
and put some gas in one day
um but you know that that was a little
alarming yeah so we said that they had a
roach chewing on a leather jacket in
Florida they'll eat anything they'll eat
anything I fell asleep in front of the
TV at my friend's house in Mississippi
[ __ ] he had a nice [ __ ] house and
everything is you know this is not a
[ __ ] Shack this is a [ __ ]
beautiful house fell asleep in front of
the television watching [ __ ] like
[ __ ] Poltergeist and stuff when I was
a kid on [ __ ]
and woke up felt something pulling on my
finger and there was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
palmetto bug eating my fingernail I was
like whoa and he went running off like
that and it runs about right ran
underneath the television
yeah they will seriously they will eat
anything yeah they will eat paper they
would like Wax they will eat soap they
will eat like anything anything well
that's why I learned like when I was
young because of and like I said we did
you know we had a clean house it was
just you can't keep them out you had to
like you couldn't have bar soap
don't leave the bar soap out because the
roaches will come out of date and eat it
you can't leave you had to put
everything in like drawers
you know what I mean yeah I even caught
some like eating paper at like books
like on your bookshelf they'll eat that
if you leave wax candles out they'll
come out at night and eat those
so
holy [ __ ] anything that they can chew is
food anything yeah it doesn't matter
yeah damn Nation alley remember that the
sci-fi movie damn nationality that's why
they've lived yeah
yeah they're gonna out they'll outlive
Humanity those [ __ ] they can survive
on anything
my ex-husband used to be so weirded out
by them that he's like he wouldn't let
me put any candles out if we put candles
out he had to like wrap like plastic
wrap around them because he was worried
that like the Roses which you know he's
probably right yeah they do
who cares though
well I'm not really care I don't want to
get up in the middle of the night and
like there'd be well I especially don't
want to get up in the middle of the
night and go in the bathroom Rex was
from Wales so he probably tripped him
out they don't have [ __ ] they don't
have big old palmetto bugs and whales
you know what's funny is that when my
ex-mother-in-law came to Florida to
visit us one time the thing that weirder
she wasn't weirded out by the I mean she
was weirded out by the bugs but I think
the thing that she was weirded out the
most about was the lizards really
lizards bothered her like she wasn't
grossed out but she just thought it was
like so weird that like every time you
went outside there was like lizards
running around yeah they run from me
she's like oh my God it's like Spain
because she'd Been to Spain and they
said they kind of have that there too
but yeah
yeah I mean and they go outside and
[ __ ] in the summertime there's
lizards everywhere yeah you every time
we go outside this house or any other
house that we've had here as soon as you
step outside 30 lizards run
I like them though they're cute they
keep the [ __ ] pests down they're
killing stuff yeah they're eating stuff
well yeah they eat bugs and they eat
each other that's another thing they're
uh you'll see a lizard that'll be that
big a little tiny tadpole type of lizard
and I was watching one of them run in
another lizard brand bite and it [ __ ]
ate it yeah they're awesome they're
cannibals I didn't realize that they
were cannibals well they'll eat anything
that's small anything is moved they're
like hey they're opportunists yeah
they're not gonna worry about it but
like I said any honestly any animal that
will eat a palmetto bug is okay by me
those are really the only animals that I
really don't have any time for
why I like spiders because spiders eat
other bugs
you know what I mean we've done all
kinds of weird [ __ ] here cleaning out
stalls and found coral snakes
deadly coral snake
they don't get too big though I had a
coral snake burn over my foot at my
grandma's house once I was walking down
the stairs and the coral snake just went
like I was like oh no yeah it didn't it
didn't bite me but they're not
aggressive
and their their fangs are kind of far
back in their mouth so that they don't
really they don't they can't really get
a bite on you and they don't bite people
unless you would really ask for it most
snakes won't I kind of feel like well
that's what um because I mean my grandma
I used to as soon as she saw a snake
even if it was uh you know a harmless
one if she saw a snake in the garden she
was gonna kill it she would cut his head
off with a shovel and I'm like can you
please not do that because a lot of
times snake what are you doing that's
what I mean it's like a lot of times
they eat pests which is better overall
even if they're poisonous
or venomous I should say
um they won't bite you unless you [ __ ]
with them yeah
they're I mean they're small you're big
so they're not going to bite you unless
you like are trying to catch it that's
usually people that get bitten by snakes
nine times out of ten they were trying
to catch that snake or sometimes
unfortunately people are kind of like
doing yard work and they accidentally
you know [ __ ] run into a lot of them
rattlesnakes [ __ ] Sidewinders out in
California uh Sidewinders out of the
desert uh rattlesnakes [ __ ] uh lots
of cottonmouth which is like a yeah we
got something it's like a water bottle
yeah we got those here too lots of those
and they're all they all give warnings
yeah you know what I mean they try to
look as poisonous as possible and you're
like okay all right let's go and then
they leave
yeah like if you get and I'm not victim
blaming I'm just saying because
sometimes it does happen by accident
because I have I've known a couple
people that were like just doing yard
work and they stuck their hand in a bush
or something like that and there was a
snake in there they didn't know about it
and then they got bit but most of the
time 99 of the time
somebody's trying to catch the snake or
kill the snake or [ __ ] with the snake in
some way and then the snake bites them
for a snake to produce that Venom it's
very caught it's very calorie costing
for them to make that Venom yeah they
don't want to have to do that they need
that to [ __ ] survive
they use little small amounts of it to
paralyze small creatures all right and
they don't want to bite anything [ __ ]
big and get in trouble yeah because they
can't eat you most people that do get
bit by a cottonmouth
or rattlesnakes
they get venom injected into them but
it's usually a warning shot which is
enough to cost you a limb
okay but they usually don't give you a
full amount my dad got bit
by a rattlesnake it was a
Diamondback out in California yeah we
have those here too yeah he got bit in a
finger he was trying to catch it yeah
we'll see there you go
like don't do that Pro tip they got him
but he gave him a [ __ ] it was kind of
a glancing blow and it was so it was a
warning strike and he was able to get it
all out of there it swelled out a little
a little bit but then it it evened out a
couple days later it didn't start eating
the flesh away people think that you get
bit and then you die no it's not what
it's like I don't know you get bit and
it's like somebody injected [ __ ]
sulfuric acid into you it eats holes in
you yeah you know when you got a good
bite
it's not a
oh my God you know what I mean I've been
injected with cyanide no this [ __ ] eats
you up it's an open wound yeah it takes
a while a [ __ ] yeah it's bad
and most of the time if you can get to a
hospital in a reasonable amount of time
you probably won't die but it's not
going to be a fun experience well
usually most people by [ __ ]
rattlesnakes don't die at all no it's
beautiful even a full strike and even
without treatment it's just that it eats
a huge [ __ ] hole in you yeah you
don't want to leave it no you don't want
to leave it it eats a hole in you and
we're talking about like the hole that
would be like the size of a softball or
a baseball that's a big size of an
orange bad and it [ __ ] [ __ ] will blow
up
and then
infection could set in and a doctor
later on was like we got to amputate
that arm
yeah I kind of feel like that's like
that that's probably what would happen
yeah that's probably what happened
I mean I don't
um nobody I nobody in my family has ever
been bitten by a snake but my brother
was bitten by a brown recluse spider
on his knee
and uh that didn't go so well
because he didn't go to the doctor for a
really long time it bit on his knee he
didn't really know about it or didn't
really do anything about it and it
swelled up and you could see the I and I
still remember this like it was
yesterday you could see the blood
poisoning going up his thigh like you
could see the red like going all the way
up his style like that and it's like
finally he went to the doctor and
they're like [ __ ] why did you take so
long to get here if this had got you
your heart you'd be dead yeah so Glenn
little chimed in corrosive enzyme yeah
exactly it's corrosive enzyme now I
don't know I've run into uh Egyptian
cobras when I was in Egypt Psalm did it
was not an aggressive snake and it ran
from us and looking at it I thought it'd
look like a [ __ ] harmless black
garden snake is what it was big it's
what it looked like like a big harmless
black garden snake running fast and we
ran alongside it we didn't want to catch
it but we ran alongside it to look yeah
just leave them alone and then it left
oh now I don't know I've heard that it's
bite is [ __ ] deadly
uh but I don't know if it's a corrosive
enzyme or something kind of like cyanide
or or that kills you I don't know I'm
not sure about covers like I think I
think a cobra paralyzes your ability to
breathe I think that's how I that's yeah
I think that's the case yeah which is so
they're all going to be a little bit
different here in the south
it's going to be cottonmouth and [ __ ]
Rattlers and it's a complete enzyme it's
like [ __ ] being injected with acid we
have cottonmouth we have uh Eastern
Diamondbacks Coral Rattler coral snake
and water moccasin yeah which is a water
moccasin is kind of like a cork well
it's a different species though those
are the four I mean we learned this in
elementary school because I you know I'm
from here and you learned in elementary
school those are the four venomous
snakes that are here and that you always
have to look out for also you have to
look out for the king snake which looks
like a coral snake but is not venomous
yeah red and black a friend of Jack red
and yellow killed a fellow yeah that's
what they are that's what they taught us
when we were kids if the red stripe
touches the yellow stripe that's a
[ __ ] what that's a [ __ ] coral
snake right if the red if the red stripe
touches the black stripe it's it's a
false then it's a king it's a king's
thing red and black friend of Jack but
see King Snake evolved to look like a
coral snake it didn't have to evolve the
Venom because it looks like a coral
snake so everyone avoids it as though it
wasn't was one but the stripe pattern is
slightly different red black kid friend
of Jack red and yellow killed a fellow
yeah that's what they that's all you
gotta know I remember us I remember them
teaching us that in like Elementary
School like I said
because like I said I'm from Florida so
they had to teach you all the venomous
snakes all the venomous spiders all the
venomous it's like Australia kind of
it's not quite as bad as Australia but
Australia's goddamn bullet ants and [ __ ]
yeah even their butt we're not quite
that bad even their bugs are evil you
know but you gotta be a man surviving
even the women got to be a man
but it's kind of a similar thing it's
kind of a similar yeah now out of them
all here in Florida the least the least
lethal least dangerous one or less
riskiest one is a moccasin
um I've never heard of anybody actually
being bit by moccasin I haven't either
now that you now that you mentioned it
yeah
python now there's something else out
here
that'll [ __ ] with your mind
that you swear to God as a poisonous
snake it's called a puff adder
and it [ __ ] blows itself up to the
biggest [ __ ] snake makes all kinds of
huffing and puffing and [ __ ] make
puts on this huge display it's not
poisonous and it looks we'll see I feel
like it looks like a it looks like a
water moccasin but it isn't it's a puff
adder and usually any animal no matter
what it is that has to like make a big
show yeah of it is usually not yeah it's
bluffing venomous but its mouth will
open up like it's [ __ ] a huge
poisonous mouth and it's [ __ ] it'll
even sometimes it'll get desperate and
turn on its back so you see it a yellow
Underside and it starts with Rising like
it's dying and that that's like when
it's really freaking the [ __ ] out and
you're like okay all right ma'am let you
go you know I mean I can't take it it's
on the safe side it's probably better to
like not [ __ ] with anything yeah
yeah because not only do we have all
that stuff but we also have like
mosquitoes that have Encephalitis we
also have ticks yeah
um you know what I mean there's all kind
of just don't go outside just alligators
alligators [ __ ] I was just watching a
video earlier that somebody posted about
a little alligator that was stalking a
snowy egret and then a bigger alligator
that came out and like was trying to eat
the littler alligator yeah I was like
yep that's Florida in a nutshell Florida
in a nutshell and like I said I've said
this on a couple shows before but I've
actually seen when I was just like
driving I was driving from Daytona to
DeLand I saw an alligator just running
across the highway
and I was like well
there he goes you know what I mean yeah
it happens it happens actually
um an alligator got run over on the road
up to my uh Elementary School when I was
kid and he was just like flat there for
a long time what's weird is that here in
Florida
that they find homicide victims the
body's a homicide victims
because when I was working at Dr Matt's
manner
which is a huge huge [ __ ] mansion
that had its own private stable and uh
Chicken Coop and all kinds of animals
what's the matter what's up no you're
not going in there she wants to go in
your car I'll show it to you in the
closet there's nothing in there I showed
you earlier he had a turkey
turkey turkey in the chicken coop and
the turkey died
and the chickens were still in there
pissed off that there was a dead turkey
laying in well you can't blame them open
their door to grab a damn dead turkey
and a [ __ ] roosters attacked me there
were two roosters they attacked me for
grabbing the [ __ ] that was we don't
want this dead turkey in here but we
also don't want you to take it here yeah
leave him alone
then the [ __ ] roosters I'm like okay
all right resident had to chase all the
[ __ ] chickens out let them go
and then I went in and got the turkey
okay
and he had a um a four-wheeler
that we used to make the turkey didn't
have before no no doctor doctor
yeah he had a four-wheeler and had a
[ __ ] uh trailer in the back so you
could run things around and spread mulch
and [ __ ]
and um
I put the turkey in the [ __ ] back of
the four-wheeler trailer
and threw him out in the back he had a
little back [ __ ] 40 type back little
lot and I said I'll come back later
and get him after I get done letting the
horses out feeding the horse to let him
out
I come back and dispose of this [ __ ]
turkey body
and it's
six o'clock in the morning it's still
early all right no food listen to her
she's asking bacon
there's nothing in there I promise she
thinks I'm hiding something in there
feed all the horses give them all their
medicine make all the shit's gonna put
them all out in all the passage pastures
everything's all [ __ ] good and go
okay I'm gonna go back there
get the turkey
give it a Christian burial
respectful [ __ ] demise
because I actually like the turkey okay
I used to spray the turkey with the hose
because it would get hot and it would
[ __ ] sit there oh bask in the damn
water I kind of feel bad about eating
them at Thanksgiving though he was old
turkey that's okay he was an albino
turkey was white I'm sitting there I'm
spraying this turkey yeah and then the
goat remember the goat Franklin go
Franco yeah Franklin would watch me
spray the turkey and then try to [ __ ]
Bogart the [ __ ] water
stand in front load give me the water
that's [ __ ] funny and [ __ ] come on I
got the hose Franklin was cool by the
way yeah Frank was [ __ ] hilarious
you couldn't keep Franklin under control
he'd do dances and [ __ ] [ __ ] try to
push on you and he wanted to play all
the time he always wanted to he always
um well because I kind of feel like well
people would bring him peppermint
candies which is like his favorite thing
yeah and they would bring him in his
pocket so like whenever he showed up
yeah if I came up and said I had never
brought him peppermint candies but he
was like kind of the main thing he leave
it alone now she's tearing down the
[ __ ] what is she doing
did she push the painting she did leave
it alone pug
she's acting up so we talked about
Franklin yeah more than Franklin do now
well he I had never given him peppermint
candy yeah but when I got there and
introduced myself to Franklin the first
thing he did was start chewing at my
pockets or where he thought my pockets
were because he thought maybe I had
peppermint candy in there yeah so like
later on I brought some peppermint candy
for him but like he thought that
everybody like had peppermint candy
goats are smarter than me and that was
his favorite thing goats are smarter
than dogs they're they're [ __ ]
hilarious anyway I go back there to go
get the [ __ ] turkey and give the
turkey a burial and that turkey had only
been out there for 45 minutes and when I
showed up it was gone
never did find the turkey somebody
turkey napped him yeah animal got him
yeah within 45 minutes well they were
like woo a whole turkey a whole [ __ ]
turkey and this was not in the country
this is
large Lots like [ __ ]
um six acres Seven Acres with mansions
on them
low profile
low profile entrances to him
and they look like something out of the
movies in that area
the guy that owns Ace Hardware one of
his Mansions there
um Dr Matt his mom made Orlando General
Hospital okay she she was made with a
donation came from a very powerful
Jewish family had a whole bunch of money
they were powerful in the medical
um industry
and it's just it was beautiful houses
like going to Disneyland it was like a
white Victorian plantation house what it
looked like with its own barn and
everything and he'd go off and [ __ ]
go to Egypt and [ __ ] and I'd take care
of his housewarm big [ __ ] um
pools out in the back or fountains and
stuff it's like something you see out of
the movies
and um he had horses so I'd take care of
all his horses and some of his friends
horses were there
I did that for how many years
I thought it was a while well you were
doing that when I met you yeah probably
two or three years I Met You in 2010
yeah 2009 2010 you were doing it then
yeah
then what happened I [ __ ] won a
lawsuit and [ __ ] started getting all
my retirement benefits and [ __ ] like
that so I didn't really have to work
don't do that anymore either it was like
yeah I could go back there and do it but
it wouldn't really be worth it you know
[ __ ] that it's hard work that my age
to do that [ __ ] well that's what I'm
saying
he paid okay but it wasn't like enough
to really make it worse yeah
because I don't know I don't know you'd
have to and it was a come and going type
of thing depending on whether or not he
was there that's what I'm saying price
would go up when he wasn't there you
know what I mean because
I was provided security and better
Services because he he could here's the
thing about Dr Matt
he had a lot of money he was very
educated he was a fun guy as big in the
science he was science nerd bios biotech
nerd
but he worked he was a [ __ ] super
hard worker that dude was not lazy and
he'd come out and do yard work he'd
[ __ ] mowers he had all of his [ __ ] to
mow his own [ __ ] Lawns make mulch
he'd [ __ ] deal with horses and
everything and he was he was running a
hospital here
doing that at the same time so he wasn't
a doctor he had doctors working for him
he'd run a whole Hospital
so but still
he wouldn't avoid work he was a
workaholic he liked farm work that was
his fantasy
but see that's good I mean like if
you're gonna because I kind of feel like
there's a lot of sort of rich people
that like the idea of that but they
don't actually want to do this she would
be involved with it yeah he would do it
so at least he knew
what it entailed and he was willing to
do it himself rather than just being
like Oh I just like the idea of this I
want to hire other people and I'm just
gonna watch them yeah no you know no
this guy Scoop the Poop out of like all
the horse dolls and [ __ ] no this guy's a
multi-multi-millionaire and he's [ __ ]
out there mowing his own lawn well I
wouldn't go what what what what's the
matter
why are you upset
she's like she's looking at something
what's the matter go ahead is it is it a
ghost what'd you say is it a ghost you
seen ghosts
you can tell me oh oh [ __ ] that's going
on what's the matter she's never done
this before
do you not like the family you don't
like the fan
[Laughter]
look at her butt [ __ ] funny what's
the matter
oh my goodness Becca made it what's up
Becca look at yeah everybody sees your
butthole that's good yeah you're putting
your ass in the camera
yeah but yeah it's Kitty anal porn she
is freaking out go ahead what are you
seeing
she's seeing I'm telling you she's
seeing ghosts man
what what's the matter
I don't see it it goes I'm telling you
she's looking around like she's like
what
what
I don't see it
thank you Victor he's looking up here
like she sees something I'm telling you
she sees [ __ ] she sees dead people
what is it I don't see it what's the
matter
huh holy [ __ ]
okay she never gets this adamant about
it what thank you Victor he says Pookie
with a little heart eyes I can't see it
pookie I don't know what you're seeing
yeah
yeah
I don't see it
this is ridiculous
what she's never done this book I mean
she does this every now and then
but never like I can't see it but
is it it's dead people right it's ghosts
she keeps looking at this and then that
let's go send it
I don't know I can't help it I don't
know what it is I can't see what you're
seeing she's like but Daddy but Daddy
yeah yeah yeah oh my goodness
it's getting late actually
what
what do you want me to do about it
she's just looking at the fan
I don't well she doesn't like the fan
for for sure I know that but because
I've taken pictures of her before and
she's like [ __ ] this turn it off Rebecca
came in she said just right at the time
been shoveling horse [ __ ] all morning
Pookie's ass the smallest but but I've
seen all morning
I didn't know you worked in the in the
industry
what's up what's the matter baby girl oh
my God you see it she's so upset you're
trying to show me something but I don't
see it is it go it's ghost right
is it it's ghosts
yeah
what
okay I'm gonna go with you okay
find out find out find out what this
situation is
yeah what is it
you guys are witnessing this [ __ ] live
okay I don't see it
she keeps looking up at the ceiling what
is it is it a demon
do you want me to take you up here
should we call the Warrens
oh [ __ ] what about what what's the
matter
is there something there
is it a demon
what is it
she's looking at it I don't like what is
she looking at
okay now I'm freaking out a little bit
what is it
yeah yeah
what's the matter I can't see it
says my daddy yeah we've had the fan on
before she wasn't this upset about it
yeah she doesn't like it but she wasn't
this upset about it I can't see it
[Laughter]
is that it
is it just the fan are you upset about
the fan or do you see something else
should we should we be worried and
shaking should we do an exercise it's
not shaking too much you don't like it
what's the matter
okay
picture says whip out the Ouija now
she's not taking me anywhere
yeah yeah what is it where are we going
Michael says Uh Russian blue she's
actually
um if you're asking about the breed
she's actually a Manx
yeah
what she's keep calling me and she's
taking me here
and then she's looking up you want to go
up here and look at it again Celeste
says ghost yeah I'm pretty sure you see
it what is it
I don't see it I have never seen her do
this before I'm not sure what it is like
she does this sometimes but not to this
not for this length of time and not to
this degree
she's looking at that damn face what's
the matter
what's the matter
okay I can't help you poop that's all I
got I'm getting [ __ ] right now yeah
okay
seeing ghosts
laughs
I tease her all the time because
sometimes every now and they're like
she'll come in she'll jump up on my desk
and then like she looks at them she's on
the floor looking at it again
what is it
okay
I don't know if you guys can hear him
but she meows every time she answers
okay I've
oh my goodness
okay
are you having some kind of like weird
premonition or something [ __ ] with me
what's going on
oh poor baby
Anthony says uh Jeff Mayer says
sometimes regarding nde pets he goes
we'll see I tease her about that all the
time like because every now and then
she'll jump up on my desk she's just
acting normal and then all of a sudden
she'll like go and she'll like look over
at something that I can't see and she's
like staring
and I'm like I'm like are you seeing
ghost okay are you seeing ghosts you can
tell me it's okay but it's like she I've
never seen her like
act like that though
is it a demon
yeah do we need to call Elizabeth Warren
do we need to have an exorcism
do we need do we need to have an
accident
I guess we do she's never done this
before either please don't step on the
keyboard please don't yeah
oh my God this is excellent excellent
this is excellent Pokey whatever it is
that you're doing I don't really know
what your deal is I've never seen you do
this before ever please don't no no no
no no no no no no no no no no okay she
doesn't know me no
okay get back on there it's okay it's
okay you can get back on there see
you can get back on there yep that's
your butt that's your butt
okay
[Laughter]
Mark says when sidetracks turns into a
haunting apparently I didn't expect that
yeah
she just keeps staring up at the ceiling
now she's like laying right there by our
toys and she just keeps going
oh my God it's the whole ceiling like a
wash with ghosts we're in trouble you
guys
we're in trouble
she's right there she and she jumped up
again and then she got up on here yeah
and was like going all like yeah you're
[ __ ] with people
she's [ __ ] she's I've never seen her
do that before I've never seen her do
that before she's blinking being cute
you're true
[Laughter]
she's throwing you trying to live in the
show at pool yeah that's what she's
doing like pretending there's ghosts
I know one thing though I kind of feel
like it's a demonic entity maybe look at
her eyes
look it around Pope what you doing she's
crazy yeah she's crazy about you but uh
I'm hungry I'll get something to eat uh
sure okay then shut it down it's [ __ ]
almost nine o'clock anyway is it we're
almost to three hours yeah I can't
believe that Pookie did that though yeah
that's so funny well you guys got a
Pookie show and um it's kind of like
that a lot she just doesn't normally
perform on camera she does [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] she's hilarious yeah she usually
does funny [ __ ] but when I try to record
her she stops doing it oh no yep cameras
on me and then she's like and then she
just tries to like eat the camera or
whatever so that's why I don't have that
many cool videos of her doing cool [ __ ]
because as soon as I start taping her
she's like yeah I'm not gonna do the
cool [ __ ] anymore so that was the first
time I've ever seen her do anything like
that she has no idea if she's a cat she
thinks she's a human being and she tries
to do a lot of the same [ __ ] that we do
that's another thing well yeah if I
start packing or unpacking things like
she'll go in to something like I'm help
packing too she tries to help me pack
she thinks it's helping but it's not you
know well she's getting in the way I
don't like to tell her that yeah what's
up what's up every time I try to like
wash the sheets and make them whatever
you feel like that I try to do she's
just gonna jump into the middle and be
like I'm helping him helping you make
the bed yeah I'm like you're you're not
but okay yeah
you're not okay shut down Jen I'll make
it something
all right you all right now Pope yeah
see your eyes you look like you saw some
ghosts okay you saw ghosts is it ghost
seriously ghost okay yeah she she
blinked you she's like yeah I'm pretty
sure it's a ghost
holy [ __ ] hopefully they don't kill us
in the night the Warrens are dead we
can't do it we'll have to summon them
through the Ouija board to have them
come help us
all right Rebecca says I'll listen to
this completely tomorrow I'm catching up
on the Zodiac Revisited today yeah that
was okay that was a good show too but
yeah we'll be back on
Sunday talking about I got a couple
ideas for movies that uh that we can do
so but I don't know which one we're
gonna do so we'll find we'll figure it
out so thanks everybody for dropping by
this evening and uh thanks for super
chats and you know we'll see you guys
again on Sunday evening we're gonna go
get something to eat and we'll see you
guys then good night